GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WELCOME TO
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE TODAY WE WILL AGAIN BE
HAVING AN IN PERSON HEARING AND
CAPITOL ROOM FOUR FORTY FOUR WE
WILL NOT BE TAKING ANY VOTES
TODAY. THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN PERSON MAY DO SO WHEN WE
OPENED PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END
OF THE HEARING. AFTER THOSE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM OF SPOKEN WE
WILL ALLOW PHONE TESTIMONY THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING THIS HEARING.
ONLINE THE PHONE NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX. TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099 AND A
STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU.
THOSE TESTIFYING WILL HAVE UP TO
ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK WE ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO ALSO- IF YOU COULD
LIKE WOULD CARE TO. TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING. BEFORE A AND- PLEASE
SEND YOUR WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO.
THE FOLLOWING EMAIL ADDRESS
BUDGET SUB THREE. THAT'S B. U.
D. G. E. T. S. U. B. NUMERAL
THREE AT A. S. SEVEN DOT CA DOT
GOV. WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH OF
FOLKS HERE TO FORM A QUORUM SO
WILL DISPENSE WITH CALLING THE
ROLE AT THIS TIME. BUT WE DO
HAVE A NON PRESENTATION CALENDAR
DO MEMBERS HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THE NON
PRESENTATION ITEMS. SEEING NONE
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR ITEMS TO BE
HEARD AND WILL TAKE THEM. OUT OF
PH<c.cyan>DER BEGIN WITH TWO FIVE</c>
THIS MORNING. THAT IS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION ALL IT'S AN
INVESTIGATION WORKLOAD TRANSFER.
DO WE HAVE- WE DO. WELCOME
EVERYONE. FROM. YOU MAY BEGIN.
TO HAVE YOU TURNED OFF THEIR-
NEVADA CHECK ONE TWO AREA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HI GOOD MORNING
HAPPY WEDNESDAY MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- KEEP TALKING
CALTRANS BUDGET OFFICER AND I'M
JOINED TODAY BY DIANE ANTHONY
WITH THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL- TODAY ISSUE FIVE IS A
NET ZERO TRANSFER I REQUEST ON
THE NET ZERO TRANSFER OF SIX
POSITIONS AND ASSOCIATED
FUNDING- FROM THE- INDEPENDENT
OFFICE OF AUDIT AND
INVESTIGATION. COME FOR TWO AS
THE OFFICE INSPECTOR GENERAL
ENTRENCHMENT POSITIONS TO THE
CALTRANS ADMINISTRATION PROGRAM
TO ESTABLISH A REESTABLISH AN
INTRO OFFICE. AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA MATERIALS THIS MORNING-
THE OFFICE TO OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL WAS
ESTABLISHED WITH THE PASSAGE
ROAD REPAIR AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS SENATE BILL ONE
AND- IT PROVIDES THE AUTHORITY
TO THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL TO EXERCISE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MAINTAINING A
FULL SCOPE. INDEPENDENT AND
OBJECTIVE AUDIT INVESTIGATIONS.
A TO PROVIDES AND READ TO THIS
NEW OFFER CULTURE. I TRANSFERRED
FORTY EIGHT. PERMANENT POSITIONS
AS WELL WORKLOAD I FROM ITS
MANAGED PROGRAM TO THE NEW
OFFICE AS WELL AS ESTABLISHED
NEW PERMANENT POSITIONS- FOR
TOTAL. POSITIONS AT THAT POINT
IN TIME I AS PART OF A RECENT-
WORKLOAD REVIEW A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT WITH THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND CALTRANS
ADMINISTRATION PROGRAM.
IDENTIFIED AS WORKLOAD THAT WAS-
CONSIDERED NON AUDIT SERVICE
MORE ADMINISTRATIVE RELATED- IT
WAS BETTER SUITED AND DETERMINE
IT WOULD PROBABLY BE BETTER
SUITED FOR INTERNAL AUDITS
OFFICE WITHIN CALTRANS TO
PERFORM THOSE FUNCTIONS- THE-
THIS TRANSFER. THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL STORY THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES- TO CONTINUE
TO OVERSEE CALTRANS AND OTHER
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES THAT
RECEIVE STATE AND FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS TO ENSURE
THOSE FUNDS ARE SPENT
EFFICIENTLY. EFFECTIVELY
ECONOMICALLY AND IN COMPLIANCE
WITH APPLICABLE STATE AND
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS- THIS
TRANSFER OF NON AUDIT SERVICES
WILL CONTINUE TO HELP THE OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON ITS CORE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES. AND DOES NOT.
WITH THE OVERSEE OVERALL
SPENDING I WITHOUT SET AGAIN I'M
JOINED TODAY WITH THAT- DIANA
AND MYSELF AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A REPORT
FROM L. A. L. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU MINUTES WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
OUR OFFICE HAS NO CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. HAVE TO.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. JAMES OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
THAT NOW BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU- WELL LET ME
ASK A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS UP
PLEASE. BOB THIS IS AN OFFICE AS
I UNDERSTAND IT- THAT PART SB
ONE WAS OPERATIONAL AND IT WAS
CLOSED. AND OUR RE OPENING AT-
ESSENTIALLY- AND RE STAFFING AND
I YOU PROVIDED SOME RATIONALE
FOR THAT BUT CAN YOU GO INTO A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL. ON WHY WE
WOULD WHAT WHY WAS A CLOSE
ORIGINALLY AND WHY IS A GOOD
IDEA TO RE OPEN IT NOW. OKAY HI.
YEAH PART OF THE WHEN THE OF
CENTER BILL ONE IDEA ARE THE
INTO UP TIME. THAT THERE ARE OF
INSPECTOR CAN WOULD THEN ON THIS
A RISK. THAT'S IDENTIFIED WITH-
IN SENATE BILL ONE FOR THOSE
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITIES BUT
ALSO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE THE
INTERNAL AUDIT SERVICES THAT
CALTRANS HAD HAD PREVIOUSLY
PROVIDED- AND THAT'S HOW WE'VE
BEEN OPERATING SINCE THEN. AND
AS PART OF THAT RECENT WORK BUT
IF IT WAS. IDENTIFIED THAT IT
WOULD BE BETTER SUITED FOR
CALTRANS TO TAKE ON TAKE BACK
THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES AND THAT-
SO THE WORKLOAD THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED INTERNAL MORE NON
AUDIT RELATED- SO THAT'S WHY THE
JOINT DECISION WAS TO. MOVE FOR
. TO BUILD. AS WELL AS SIX
POSITIONS PERFORM THAT WERE SO A
WAY STILL BE AS AND GENERAL'S-
FUNCTIONS THAT'S NOT PART OF
THIS UNIT OUT RIGHT YES. IS
THERE ADDITIONAL TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT'S NEEDED TO MAKE
THIS CHANGE- BECAUSE OF SB ONE I
AM NOT AS FAR AS WE UNDERSTAND
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO TRANSFER THE
RESOURCES BACK THROUGH THIS BUT-
THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL OR
FINANCE OR PROCESS ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. I'M ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE
WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELLO
WE WANT TO AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WILL JUST TOLD US ITEM
OPEN AND TAKE A VOTE TODAY. OUR
NEXT ITEM WILL- TAKE US BACK TO
THE BEGINNING OF THE- COVERED
ONLY- OF THE ITEMS TO BE HEARD
TO- MOVE OF ISSUE NUMBER ONE. IN
FORT NATURE SOLUTIONS.
FOR MISTER CHAIR YES- THEY'VE
ASKED ME TO TRY TO HELP OUT OF
HOUSING WHERE THEY HAVE SOME
SHORTAGES- AS A RESULT OF SOME
ABSENCES AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US CAN'T BE HERE AND
SHE'S ASKED ME TO ASK SOME
QUESTIONS- I JUST WANT TO GO
DOWN AND GET THEM STARTED ON
HOUSING WITH HER. OKAY BACK THEY
DO SO ON THIS THE. HELLO THIS IS
ITEM I HAVE. ON I TELL YOU WE
DESTROY THIS OUT LONG AS. YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU GET THE ITEM TO.
STRETCHING BACK BE A SO YOU'RE-
ARE ITEM TO. I TO BUY I THOUGHT
WERE AND I ONCE I'VE- AYE I GOT
IT BONTA. OKAY AS TO- IF WE NEED
TO WILL TRY TO TEE UP THREE AND
COME BACK TO ISSUE TO START.
THAT'S HELPFUL. THE RIVER IS
AVAILABLE- ALL RIGHT SO I
BELIEVE WE HAVE- DEPUTY
SECRETARY HANDS- INDIVIDUALS WHO
VISIT RIGHT. PLEASE THANK YOU-
SO MUCH YES MY IS THE MON HANSEN
I AM THE DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE AT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY PLAN TO BE HERE
THANK YOU FOR. HAVING ME I'M
JENNIFER NORRIS SOME DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR BIODIVERSITY AND
HABITAT AT THE RESOURCE AGENCY
THANK YOU. JUST GONNA LAY OUT A
COUPLE OF- THAT IMPORTANT POINTS
FOR BACKGROUND AND THEN HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS- I JUST WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE
LEGISLATURE FIGURE PARTNERSHIP-
ON ADVANCING A RECORD SETTING
CLIMATE BUDGET LAST YEAR AND FOR
INCLUDING. THIRD THAT I TALK
ABOUT TODAY WHICH IS THE NATURAL
WORKING LAND SECTOR MAKES UP
APPROXIMATELY 90% OF
CALIFORNIA'S ONE HUNDRED IN
PHILLY ONE HUNDRED AND FIVE
MILLION ACRES OF FARMS FORESTS
WETLANDS DESERT'S COMMUNITY
GREEN SPACES AND MORE. WELL
CALIFORNIA'S EFFECTIVELY
CHAMPION AND CLIMBED ACTION
ACROSS MANY SECTORS SUCH AS
ENERGY TRANSPORTATION AND
INDUSTRIAL PROCESS THESE. ARE
STATE HAS HISTORICALLY NOT
EMPHASIZE THE ROLE OF OUR LANDS
IN CLIMATE ACTION. TREES PLANTS
GRASSES AND SOILS PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN REMOVING AND
STORING CARBON FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE AND WHEN OUR
LANDSCAPES ARE HEALTHY THEY CAN
PROVIDE A POWERFUL SINK TO
ABSORB GREENHOUSE GASES AND THEY
CAN HELP US MOVE TOWARD OUR GOAL
OF CARBON NEUTRALITY. HEALTHY
LAND SO PROTECT PEOPLE AND
NATURE FROM THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND BUILD OUR
RESILIENCE TO FUTURE CLIMATE
RISKS. CERTAINLY THE OPPOSITE IS
ALSO TRUE WHEN OUR LANDS ARE
UNHEALTHY THEY BECOME ANOTHER
SOURCE OF CARBON POLLUTION
RELEASING MORE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN THE STORE. AND
UNDERMINING OUR EFFORTS TO
ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY. IN
ADDITION UNHEALTHY LANDS
INCREASE CLIMATE RISKS TO PEOPLE
AND NATURE. AND THEY THEMSELVES
ARE MORE VULNERABLE TO FUTURE
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS SO A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THIS IS THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING TO RESTORE FOREST
HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA. THESE
EFFORTS PROTECT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THEY REDUCE RISKS
AND BUILD THE RESILIENCE OF OUR
FORESTS TO WITHSTAND FUTURE
CLIMATE IMPACTS. AND PROTECT
REFUGIA WHICH ARE PLACES WHERE
PLANTS AND ANIMALS CAN THRIVE IN
A CHANGING CLASS. SAN ALSO. ON
OUR GREENHOUSE AND GOALS.
INCREASING THEIR ABILITY TO
SAFELY AND SUSTAINABLY STORE
CARBON OVER THE LONG TERM AND
REDUCING EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. IN
ADDITION TO THE CLIMATE SPECIFIC
BENEFITS- OF THESE KINDS OF
INVESTMENTS THEY CAN ALSO
STRENGTHEN OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES STRATEGICALLY REDUCE
RISKS TO CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
COMMUNITIES THEY CAN IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES SAFEGUARD
MUCH OF THE STATE'S WATER
SUPPLY. PROJECT ESSENTIAL
BIODIVERSITY AND EXPAND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH TOURISM
RECREATION AND SUSTAINABLE WOOD
PRODUCTS AND JOBS. THE PATH TO A
CARBON NEUTRAL EQUITABLE AND
RESILIENT FUTURE IS NARROWING.
AND THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE OCCURRING FASTER AT A
GREATER MAGNITUDE AND WITH
GREATER UNCERTAINTY THAN PREDICT
. THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE
CALLS FOR DRIVING DOWN EMISSIONS
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY BUILDING
CLIMATE RESILIENCE IN EVERY
SECTOR INCLUDING OUR NATURAL
WORKING LAND SECTOR. A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON ADMINISTRATION
ACTION TO DATE IN OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY THE GOVERNOR CALLED FOR
ACCELERATED USE OF NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS TO DELIVER ON
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE CHANGE AND
BIODIVERSITY GOALS THROUGH
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND EIGHTY TO
TWENTY. LAST MONTH WE RELEASED
THE FIRST EVER STRATEGY TO GUIDE
AND ACCELERATE CLIMATE ACTION
ACROSS OUR NATIONAL WORKING
LANDS. AND IN ADDITION TO
OUTLINING HOW MANAGING LANCE CAN
SUPPORT OUR CLIMATE GOALS THE
STRATEGY ALSO IDENTIFIES HOW
THESE ACTIONS CAN INCREASE
EQUITY PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY. NUMBER TWO NINETY AND
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
BIODIVERSITY. AT THE SAME TIME
WE RELEASED OUR PATHWAYS TO
THIRTY BY THIRTY STRATEGY TO
ACHIEVE OUR GOAL OF CONSERVING
30% OF OUR LANDS AND COASTAL
WATERS BY TWENTY THIRTY. THIRTY
THIRTY IS PART OF AN
INTERNATIONAL MOVEMENT TO
PROTECT NATURE AND THE LIFE
SUPPORT SYSTEMS ARE PLANET.
CALIFORNIA'S THIRTY BY THIRTY
INITIATIVE WILL CONSERVE OUR
LANDS AND COASTAL WATERS TO
SAFEGUARD OUR UNIQUE FILED BY
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY INCREASE
ACCESS TO NATURE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND DELIVER
CLIMATE ACTION. WORK IS ALREADY
UNDERWAY TO SUPPORT NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND AS
NOTED AT THE OUTSET THE GOVERNOR
AND MEMBERS A LEGISLATURE
COMMITTED RECORD FUNDING TO DO
MORE THROUGH THE MULTI BAND
MULTI YEAR BENEFIT. MY GOD MULTI
YEAR BUDGETS APPROVED LAST YEAR.
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET IN
COMMITTED ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND OVER THREE
YEARS FROM MULTI BENEFIT NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES APPROX THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TWO MILLION TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE SECOND YOUR INVESTMENTS. AB
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE SUPPORTING
IMMEDIATE DROUGHT RESPONSE FOR
COMMUNITIES AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND STRENGTHENS LONG
TERM WATER RESILIENCE FOR
NATURAL SYSTEMS IMPROVE
RESILIENCE OF THE STATE'S
FORESTS AND WILDLANDS TO
WITHSTAND LONG TERM CLIMATE
THREATS. AND FOR PROTECTION FOR
WILDFIRE BILLABLE COMMUNITIES. A
MULTI BENEFIT BASED THAT DELIVER
ON THE EXECUTIVE I JUST
MENTIONED TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE EXPAND OUTDOOR ACCESS
PROTECT BIODIVERSITY. COMMUNITY
GREENING INITIATIVES THAT
SUPPORT THE STATE'S CLIMATE AND
EQUITY GOALS SCALE SUPPORT FOR
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
PLANNING AND PRACTICES. ACTION
FOR THE OCEAN CALIFORNIA'S
COASTAL RESTORATION PROJECTS AND
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
FUNDING THAT CREATES ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND NATURE BASED
SECTORS SUCH AS AGRICULTURE
FORESTRY AND CLIMATE RESTORATION
. THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ALSO INCLUDED SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SIXTY EIGHT MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND OVER TWO YEARS TO
KICKSTART IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
CLIMATE SMART STRATEGY AND
PATHWAYS TO THIRTY BY THIRTY. WE
RELEASED A PROPOSED APPROACH TO
INVESTING THESE FUNDS IN APRIL.
IT BUILDS ON EXISTING FUNDING TO
ADDRESS THE CLIMATE BIODIVERSITY
CRISES IT UNDERSCORES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
ADVANCING EQUITY AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY. AND OFFERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE BOTH
INITIATIVES IT WAS DEVELOPED IN
DIRECT RESPONSE TO FIVE KEY
PRIORITIES THAT EMERGED FROM OUR
YEAR LONG PLUS PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
TO DEVELOP BOTH OF THOSE
STRATEGIES. BUCKET IS THE- THE
PROPOSAL IS INCLUDED IN THE
AGENDA THERE'S A CHART SO THE
FIRST BUCKET IS ALL ABOUT
ACCELERATING IMPLEMENTATION.
WE'RE PROPOSING TO BUILD ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INVESTMENTS THROUGH THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR PROGRAMS THAT FIND STATEWIDE
NATURE BASED SOLUTION
IMPLEMENTATION. THE MAJORITY OF
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
TO PROGRAMS THAT NO LONGER HAVE
THUNDER FUNDING AVAILABLE. OR IN
SOME CASES ARE YOU. THE SECOND
BUCKET OF OUR- PROPOSAL- REALLY
. X. TO THE- NEED FOR STATE
SUPPORT FOR REGIONAL ACTION IN
THE SPACE SO WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL TO WORK ALONG SIDE SO
MANY CLIMATE AND CONSERVATION
LEADERS MANAGING LANDS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I'M THESE INCLUDE
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES FEDERAL AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
FARMERS AND RANCHERS LAND
TRUST'S COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IS COMMUNITY
SERVICE DISTRICT AND MORE
THERE'S A LOT OF PLAYERS IN THIS
SPACE AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR ALL
OF THEIR WORK. IT'S OUR PROPOSAL
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION AT TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE MILLION TO SUPPORT THEIR
EFFORTS AND ACCELERATING NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS. THE THIRD AREA
OF FOCUS IT IS EXPANDING ACT
EDUCATIONAL AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG CLIMATE
LEADERS AND CALIFORNIA. AND WHEN
WE DID OUR GAUGE MEANT ACROSS
ALL REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA WE
HEARD SIGNIFICANT INTEREST IN
DELIVERING ON TO THE GOVERNOR'S
CLIMATE AN OPPORTUNITY AGENDA.
THEY'RE EXPANDING OUR
RESTORATION ECONOMY JOBS AND
MARKETS THAT CONSTRUCT OPERATE
MAINTAIN OR SUPPORT NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS IS THE LEGACY OF
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE AND ARE
PROPOSING TO INVEST FIFTY TWO
MILLION FOR THE STATE COR. TO
SUPPORT PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION
AND TRAINING AND SUPPORT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING LOCAL CORE AND A NEW
TRIBAL COURT. THE FOR THE AREA
OF FOCUS OF OUR PROPOSAL IS
PARTNERING WITH CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES WERE
PROPOSING TO INVEST ONE HUNDRED
MILLION TO SUPPORT TRIBAL
INITIATIVES THAT ADVANCE SHARED
CLIMATE AND BIODIVERSITY GOALS
THROUGH NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS.
THESE INCLUDE RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE
CAPACITY BUILDING AND TECHNICAL
SUPPORT. TRIBAL NATURE BASED
CLIMATE CONSERVATION PROGRAMS
INCREASE ACCESS AND CO
MANAGEMENT OF LANDS AND
ANCESTRAL LAND RETURNS. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL BE INFORMED
THROUGH A TRIBALLY LED AND
INFORMED PROCESS AND WAS
DEVELOPED REPUBLICAN GAUGE MEANT
AND GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
CONSULTATIONS WITH OVER SEVENTY
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES. AND THE FIFTH AND FINAL
AREA OF FOCUS IS- AS SET OF
PROPOSALS THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
ADVANCE STRATEGIC INITIATIVES-
WE'RE PROPOSING TEN MILLION. AT
FOR THIS BUCKET IT'S GOING TO
ADVANCE THE NUMBER OF NEAR TERM
PRIORITIES THAT REQUIRE-
PILOTING CONSULTATION AND
ANALYSIS CONSULTANT SERVICES.
THE MAJORITY OF THE FUNDS WILL
SUPPORT LAUNCHING A PILOT
COMPOSTING PROGRAM IN ADDITION
THESE FUNDS WILL SUPPORT CA
NATURE WHICH IS A SUITE OF
INTERACTIVE MAPPING AND VISUAL
VISIBLE IT VISUALIZATION TOOLS
SORRY. TO ADVANCE THIRTY BY
THIRTY AND THEY'RE ALSO GONNA BE
USED TO INFORM OUR APPROACH- TO
A NUMBER OF AREAS OF NEAR TERM
FOCUS FOR STATE ACTION THAT
REQUIRE CONSULTANTS SERVICES
EXPERT RECOMMENDATIONS
CONVENING. ANALYSIS AND
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
PARTNERSHIP AND I CAN GO INTO
MORE DETAIL LATER IF NECESSARY
SO WE KNOW THAT SUCCESS IN THE
SECTOR REQUIRES COLLECTIVE
ACTION AND CREATIVITY AND THE
STATE REPS HERE TODAY IT ACROSS
pGRATEFUL TO PARTNER WITH ALL OF
THOSE I MENTIONED EARLIER AND
THOSE WHO I DID NOT MENTION PER
ABSOLUTELY DRIVING ON THE SPACE-
TO DO. IT STARTED SO. IT'S GOING
TO TAKE ALL OF US TO ADDRESS THE
CRIME CRISIS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME HERE TODAY
TO TALK ABOUT THE PROPOSAL AND
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU- BUT I WILL HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS BUT- LET'S HEAR
FROM ALEJO FIRST. GOOD MORNING
TERRY MEMBERS HAILING CHRISTINE
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE JUST HAVE A FEW HIGH
LEVEL COMMENTS ON THE PACKAGE-
FOR YOU TODAY. I'M SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WANTED TO POINT
OUT IS THAT THE PACKAGE IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOALS AND
PLANS- SO I'VE YOU HEARD THERE
ARE A FEW DIFFERENT PLANS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS- COMPLETED
OVER THE LAST YEAR OR SO-
INCLUDING THIRTY BY THIRTY. THE
NATURAL WORKING LANDS CLIMATE
START SMART STRATEGIES AND AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER. AND THE REALLY
THOSE ARE WHAT'S INFORMING AND
DRIVING THIS- CERTAINLY TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE AT
AGREES IN CONCUR WITH THOSE
PRIORITIES IN THOSE PLANS- WE
THINK THAT YOU KNOW THAT THESE-
THAT THE PACKAGE HELPS. HELPS TO
PUSH THOSE FORWARD. HOWEVER IF
THE ADMINISTRATION BURKE THE
MINISTRATIONS PERSPECTIVE MAYBE
A LITTLE DIFFERENT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE LEGISLATURE
HAS DIFFERENT PRIORITIES. I'M
CERTAINLY. THERE COULD BE
CHANGES THAT THAT MIGHT BE
MERITED. I'M THE SECOND. POINT I
WANTED TO BRING UP IS THAT-
MEASURABLE GOALS- SO IN SOME
CASES SOME OF THE PROGRAMS HAVE
IDENTIFIED GOALS FOR EXAMPLE THE
NUMBER OF ACRES TO BE TREATED OR
PURCHASED HOWEVER IN OTHER CASES
THERE ISN'T THAT TYPE OF
INFORMATION- THAT MAKES IT A
LITTLE BIT HARD FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASSESS OF REALLY
WHAT WOULD BE H. FROM THAT THE
PLAN. ON WHAT THIS IS THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE THE PROGRAM'S HOW
CLOSE THIS WILL GET US TO THOSE
GOALS TO BE HEARD ABOUT YOU KNOW
WE HEARD HEARD ABOUT THIRTY BY
THIRTY I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THE ACTUAL QUESTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IS OKAY
IF WE- IF WE- THIS PACKAGE. YOU
KNOW WHERE WILL WE BE WE'RE- FOR
AT 24% NOW. WITH THIS BRING US
TO. 26% 28% WHERE WILL IT BRING
US. ON THAT THAT'S A DIFFICULT
QUESTION TO ANSWER AND ONE THAT-
THAT WE DON'T REALLY HAVE THE
INFORMATION YET TO ASSESS. FOR
THIS PACKAGE- AND THEN ALSO IF
IT MAKES A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO HOLD
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE.
AFTER THE FACT- WITH REGARD TO
WHAT WHAT WAS ACHIEVED FROM THE
PACKAGE. I'M SO WE DO THINK
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER.
AREAS WHERE THERE IS NO CLEAR
MEASURABLE PLAN- BECAUSE WE
THINK THOSE ARE YOU KNOW ARE
AREAS THAT- ESPECIALLY THOSE
AREAS REALLY COULD BE COST
EFFECTIVE WE THINK THAT. THAT
COULD BE SOMETHING TO LOOK AT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT SOME PROGRAMS
APPEAR MORE- APPROPRIATE FOR ONE
TIME FUNDING THAN OTHERS SO THIS
PACKAGE IS A TWO YEAR PACKAGE
AND THAT WAS CONSISTENT WITH THE
AGREEMENT. ON THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MADE LAST YEAR. BUT
SOMETIMES THE PROGRAM'S REALLY
NATURALLY WORK FOR ONE TIME
FUNDING IF YOU'RE DOING YOU KNOW
MAYBE. PURCHASING EASEMENTS
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS THAT'S
THAT'S KIND OF A NATURAL ONE
TIME FUNDING ACTIVITY. OTHER
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES STATE
GRAZING. YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S
THE TYPE OF ACTIVITY THAT-
PROBABLY HAVE TO HAPPEN. OTLEY
OVERTIME IT HAS TO HAPPEN N AN
ONGOING BASIS TO BE REALLY FULLY
EFFECTIVE. AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
IS WHETHER THERE ARE CERTAIN
ASPECTS CERTAIN PIECES OF THIS
PACKAGE- THAT WOULD REALLY
BENEFIT MORE FROM ONGOING
FUNDING. UNLESS FROM THIS ONE
TIME APPROACH. I'M WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE. THAT ABOUT THREE QUARTERS
OF THE PACKAGES EXCLUDABLE FROM
THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT.
BUT THERE THERE'S ABOUT A-
HUNDRED MILLION BUT TWO HUNDRED.
NOT EXCLUDABLE THAT'S ANOTHER
THING TO CONSIDER FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER AS YOUR
SORT OF FORMING YOUR BUDGET
LOOKING AT THE ARCHITECTURE OF
THE BUDGET- TO THINK ABOUT.
WHETHER YOU WANTED. TO THROUGH
DIRECT MORE MONEY POTENTIALLY
TOWARDS THOSE EXCLUDABLE
PURPOSES- WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THERE MIGHT BE OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES THAT COULD BE AVAILABLE
TO SUPPORT SOME OF THE
COMPONENTS OF THE PACKAGE.
SPECIFICALLY SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED IN THIS
PACKAGE HAVE BEEN SUPPORTED BY
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND IN THE PAST- AND WE THINK
THAT. IS A FUNDING SOURCE THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE POTENTIALLY
TO FIND SOME OF THESE
ACTIVITIES- IF THAT WORD THAT
THE DESIRE OF THE LEGISLATURE
SO. I'M TO GIVE YOU SOME OPTIONS
IN TERMS OF CRAFTING YOUR BUDGET
- WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S-
POTENTIAL OVERLAPPING PROGRAMS
FUNDED IN THIS AND OTHER
PACKAGES. OF FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S
FUNDING FOR THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAM THERE'S ALSO
FUNDING THE WELFARE PACKAGE FOR
THAT. THIS PACKAGE THIS. IN THIS
PACKAGE IS DIRECTED TOWARDS
PROGRAMS ARE PROJECTS THAT HAVE
A GRADING COMPONENT- WORDS
THAT'S NOT THE CASE FOR THE
WELFARE PACKAGE BUT- YOU KNOW
IT'S STILL SIMILAR PROGRAM- ALSO
WITH WHAT. A WILD WILDLIFE
CROSSINGS FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S
SOME FINDING OTHER PLACES IN THE
BUDGET. SO YOU'LL JUST WANT TO
LOOK HOLISTICALLY- BECAUSE THESE
ARE SUCH CROSS CUTTING ISSUES
RIGHT AND- THEY'RE ONES THAT
ARE. BUT SHOW UP SOMETIMES IN
OTHER PACKAGES AND OTHER
PROPOSALS. I'M SO IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HAVE THAT SORT OF BROUGHT A
FEW. I WOULD SEVEN. THIRTY
DETAIL ON SOME OF THE COMPOUND
AND SERVE THE OF THE- I'M FOR
EXAMPLE- ONE OF THE PIECES THAT
WAS NOTED WITH THAT HUNDRED
MILLION FOR TRIBAL- PROGRAMS- WE
THINK IT'S- CERTAINLY
APPROPRIATE. TIME TO INVEST IN
AND- THE AREA SUPPORTING TRIBES.
ARE BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
A LITTLE BIT CHALLENGING FOR
LEGISLATORS THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
DETAIL ON HOW THAT MONEY WOULD
BE SPENT. ON SOME OF THE THINGS
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS WELL-
WHETHER IT WOULD LIKE TO. KIND
OF CREATE SOME STATUTORY
STRUCTURE OR SOME PRIORITIES FOR
THOSE FUNDS- ANOTHER AREA WHERE-
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF DETAIL IS
ON THE- WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD FUNDING. OF THE FUNDING
COULD GO TO SIX DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS. THAT THE BOARD WOULD
BE. WOULD BE. IN THE POSITION OF
THE FIGHTING HOTEL THOSE FINE
THE PUBLIC AND- TO THE APPROACH
. I'M AGAINST THE BOARD MORE
FLEX- BUT ALSO TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PRIORITIES FOR
THOSE FUNDS THAT COULD. YOU
COULD- MEMORIALIZE THOSE. I'M
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES-
THE FINAL POINT I'D LIKE TO
BRING UP IS- THAT THE PACKAGE
LIKE SORT OF AN OVERALL APPROACH
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY AND
REPORTING. WE THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY
AT STAKE SOME OF THESE ARE YOU
KNOW THE NUMBER OF CASES THEIR
NEW PROGRAMS- OR IN SOME CASES
THERE EVEN PILOT PROGRAMS- THE
LEGISLATURES WE THINK THAT I
WANT TO KNOW. WHAT WAS ACHIEVED
FROM THESE FUNDS- SO THAT WE CAN
INFORM FUTURE DECISIONS FUTURE
FUNDING. I DETERMINE WHETHER WE
WANT TO EXTEND FUNDING BEYOND
TWO YEARS IN SOME CASES FOR
THESE PROGRAMS- SO. WE THINK
THAT'S AN AREA WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL PROBABLY WANNA
WANNA CONSIDER SOME WHICH-
PACKAGE BEST. THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HI MORNING
LET'S TO OF FINE. THAT WOULD
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE SET
ASIDE WAS NEGOTIATED AS PART OF
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
CLIMATE BUDGET. NOT THE
AGREEMENT WAS TO PROVIDE SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND OVER TWO
YEARS SO THIS PROPOSALS INTENDED
TO BE CONSISTENT WITH THAT
AGREEMENT. AND THAT THEREFORE
INCLUDES FUNDING PROPOSED ON A
ONE TIME BASIS HOWEVER WE ALSO
DID WANT TO NOTE. THAT MANY
PROGRAMS HAVE EXTENDING
CONFERENCE AND AVAILABILITY TO
ALLOW FUNDING TO BE AVAILABLE
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS SO. MOST OF
THE NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS AS
WELL AS REGIONAL ACTION PROGRAMS
HAVE TWO TO THREE YEARS TO
ENCUMBER FUNDING. AND THEN
FINALLY AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED TO
BE PLANS THAT INFORMS THE
ALLOCATIONS OF THIS PACKAGE. OUR
NEWLY RELEASED SO WE REALLY SEE
THIS PACKAGE AS PRIORITIZING
FUNDING ON A SHORT TERM BASIS TO
JUMPSTART IMPLEMENTATION. OF
THESE PROGRAMS WHILE PROVIDING
TIME TO LET YOU WAIT WHERE
ONGOING FUNDING COULD BE MOST
EFFECTIVE. SO I CAN ASK IN THE
MEDIA FOLLOW UP QUESTION- JUST
SO THAT I UNDERSTAND TO- HOW
THIS FUNDING WILL WORK- AND I'M-
JUST- RANDOMLY- CHOOSING THE-
WETLANDS RESTORATION PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES FIFTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS- IN THE- BUDGET YEAR-
AND ZERO FOR- FOR THE- FOR THE
OUT HERE- M. I. A. I UNDERSTAND
CORRECTLY THAT THAT FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE
ENCUMBERED SO THAT IT COULD BE.
SPENT OVER A MULTI YEAR PERIOD
OF TIME THAT'S CORRECT THAT
FUNDING WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
THREE YEARS. THANK YOU. I'M SO
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS
SAID THAT ARE ALREADY EMBEDDED
IN THE- IN THE AGENDA AND THE-
THE FIRST ONE- INQUIRES SO WHY
WE ARE SHIFTING FUNDING. FOR
WILDLIFE QUARTERS WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT THIS COMMITTEE
HAS LONG SUPPORTED- AND I YOU
KNOW I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- BUT THE PAST FINDINGS
GONE THROUGH THE- WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND IT'S
PROPOSED TO NOW CREATE A SECOND
PROGRAM WITH- DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE WHAT'S THE
REASON FOR THAT WHY IS THAT WHAT
WAS THAT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING. HATCHER OF THEM JENNIFER
NORRIS CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
AGENCY THANKS FOR THE QUESTION I
THINK THE ANSWER REALLY IS ABOUT
EXPEDITING THESE PROJECTS- THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE WORKS VERY CLOSELY
WITH PARTNERS ON THE GROUND TO
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES FOR BOTH
FISH PASSAGE AND WILDLIFE
CROSSINGS. WHEN JENNA FIVE ONE
OF THE PROJECTS THEY THEN HAVE
TO APPLY TO THE WCB FOR THAT
FUNDING TO GIVE THE SOURCE OF
FUNDS TO DFW WOULD ELIMINATE
THAT THREE TO FOUR MONTHS DELAY
AND ALLOW THEM TO PARTNER MORE
DIRECTLY AND HAVE ASSURANCE THAT
THESE PROJECTS CAN MOVE FORWARD
SO IT'S REALLY JUST AN
EFFICIENCY AND IT IT RECOGNIZES
DSW'S IMPORTANT ROLE. IN WORKING
WITH PARTNERS. SO ARE YOU
PROPOSING TO MOVE ALL OF THIS
KIND OF FUNDING OVER TO- DFW NO
WE THINK HAVING TO STREAMS OF
FUNDING ALLOWS US TO WORK WITH A
BROADER ARRAY OF PARTNERS AROUND
THE STATE. OKAY OF. THE
COMMISSION FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON
THAT SPECIFIC CHURCH THING AND
THAT IS SO IF- IF DFW HAS
EXHAUSTED THEIR FUNDS THEY COULD
pRIGHT FOR THE FUNDING OR ABOUT
THE OTHER WAY AROUND COULD
PEOPLE APPLY TO DFW FOR THEIR
FUNDING. IF THAT'S TRUE BECAME
LOOK AT YOU I THINK THAT'S RIGHT
I BELIEVE WE HAVE THE DIRECTOR
AVAILABLE REMOTELY YEAH LET'S DO
THAT YEAH AND JUST TO FOLLOW UP
ON THAT SO IF YOU- IF YOU HAVE A
PROJECT- THAT WOULD SEEM. QUITE
LOGICAL FOR THE APPLICANT TO
APPLY TO BOTH AGENCIES. AND THAT
SEEMS MORE COMPLEX TO ME BUT AT
LEAST FROM NAY- PERSPECTIVE OF-
OF THE- PROJECT MANAGERS. LET'S
BRING IN DOCTOR BOTTOM AND SEE
IF HE CAN. HELP US WALK THROUGH
AN EXAMPLE MAYBE. THANK YOU
CHAIR FOR THE QUESTION AND THOSE
ARE GREAT ANSWERS BUT- IT'S N.
C. DEPUTY SECRETARIES I THINK
THERE ARE SEVERAL BENEFITS. FROM
THIS APPROACH BUT. MOST
IMPORTANTLY I'D SAY I DON'T
THINK IT'S AN EITHER OR I DON'T
THINK IT'S EITHER W. C. B. OR
DEPARTMENT. BECAUSE THE SCALE OF
THE CHALLENGE AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF FIXING THESE QUARTER PROBLEMS
IS SO LARGE IT'S GOING TO TAKE
IN ALL THE ABOVE AND EVERYBODY.
SO HERE ARE A COUPLE OF THE
BENEFITS. FIRST I THINK IT'S
EXPERIENCE IN HISTORY. THE
LEGISLATURE IS FUNDED OVER THE
DECADE I'VE BEEN DIRECTOR OF
VARIETY OF THINGS THAT HAVE
PRODUCED THE EVIDENCE AND THE
INFORMATION WE'VE DONE THE
ESSENTIAL MAPPING OF ALL THE
LIKELY TOP TIER CORRIDOR
CHALLENGES WE'VE DONE THE SAME
THING ON THE FISH PASSAGE FROM
ALONG THE WHOLE COASTAL ZONE.
THE STATE'S. AND SEE SO WE HAVE
THE IN HOUSE SCIENTIST WHO ARE
THE EXPERTS ON THE BEARS AND THE
BOBCATS AND- THE CRITTERS THAT
EITHER ARE AFFECTED BY OR WILL
BENEFIT FROM. A SECOND- BENEFIT
IS IT'S POTENTIALLY FASTER AS A
DEPUTY SECRETARY NORRIS
MENTIONED. SO TO TAKE AN EXAMPLE
IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TOOK TO
DROUGHT FUNDING THE DEPARTMENT-
PURSUED A GRANT FROM THE W. C.
B. TO SPORT FISH PASSAGE
PROJECTS AND THE BOARD PROCESS
ADDED ABOUT THREE MONTHS TO THE
OVERALL TIMELINE FOR US TO GET
THE MONEY OUT IN THE FIELD TO
FIX SOME- CORRIDOR PROBLEMS SO
THERE IS A FASTER BENEFIT
POTENTIALLY. THIRD BENEFIT THERE
ARE SYNERGIES AT THE VERY TIME.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE BUDGET
FOR DOING THE ACTUAL PROJECTS.
THE DEPARTMENT WILL ALSO BE
CHARGED WITH IMPLEMENTING AS AN
EXAMPLE SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY
. WHICH IS THE STRUCTURE TO
CREATE THE MITIGATION CREDITS
POTENTIALLY FOR PROPONENTS WHO
ARE DOING THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS AND I THINK HAVING SOME
FUNDING AT THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE DEPARTMENT ENGAGED IN THOSE
VENUES COULD CREATE SYNERGIES
THAT ALLOW US TO DO MORE
PROJECTS. NEXT IN A FIT IN THIS
ONE'S PRETTY DIRECT I THINK IN
ALMOST OVERLY BLUNT. I MAY GET
AN ABILITY TO TALK TO CALTRANS
IN A DIFFERENT PARTNERSHIP
CONTEXT IF OUR DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY HAS SOME SEED MONEY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO DOING THESE
PROJECTS. AND THEN THE LAST
BENEFIT IS THE DEPARTMENT IS
ACTIVELY ENGAGED WITH OUR SISTER
FEDERAL AGENCIES AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENTOF THE INTERIOR
NATIONALLY WHO IS MANAGING ITS
OWNS FUND FOR THESE PURPOSES AND
US HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF
FUNDING. MY ALLOW US TO LEVERAGE
ALL OF THAT BETTER AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR A HALF AN FOR THAT
ANSWER. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS HEY
ADAM ALL OF THE I AG I CAN
APPRECIATE THE BENEFITS OF THE
CHANGE I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- IT. IF THE BOTH PARTS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR GOOD PROJECTS
THAT'S ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. THEN
I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THAT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
MAKING THE PROCESS MORE COMPLEX-
AND- WE'RE PROVIDING. CUT UP
MULTIPLE PATHWAYS BUT- NOT
ADDITIONAL COMPLEXITY- THAT NEXT
QUESTION- A RELEASE TITLED-
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS PROGRAM.
OF WHAT TYPES OF ACTIVITIES
SAID- DO YOU ENVISION BEING
FUNDED BY THOSE AND THEN
FOLLOWING ON- WITH- THE- ELIAS'S
COMMENTS CAN YOU DISCUSS SO WHAT
KIND OF METRICS WILL BE USED TO
ASSESS THOSE PROGRAMS AND-
DETERMINE THEIR SUCCESS. BUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH TERRY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS- FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT TODAY ON THE TRIBAL
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS- PIECE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
FOR A NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
SATISFIED AND ALSO WHEN YOU TO
THINK OF THE LEGISLATURE FOR.
HEALTH PARTNERSHIP IN ADDRESSING
HISTORICAL ROCKS I TOWARDS
CALIFORNIA AMERICANS AND TRIBES
UNDISPUTED TO THE HEALING. HI MY
NAME IS GINNY BABY THOMPSON AND
I'M THE ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
TRIBAL AFFAIRS AT THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. AND TO
RESPOND TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
WHAT TYPES OF ACTIVITIES WILL BE
FUNDED IN THE TRAP. THE
SOLUTIONS PROGRAM- WE REALLY ARE
SEEING THIS PROGRAM IS BEING A
TRIBALLY LED PROCESS AND WORKING
IN COLLABORATION AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES. ARE
THROUGH CONSULTATIONS ALSO
THROUGH A- A TRIBAL ADVISORY
COUNCIL AND BASED OFF OF OUR- OF
OVER SEVENTY DIFFERENT-
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
CONSULTATIONS WE HAD IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF. A NETWORK LAND
CLIMATE SMART STRATEGY THE
PATHWAYS A THIRTY BY THIRTY
STRATEGY AND SO WITH ALL OF THE
THAT OUTREACH IN COLLABORATION-
WE ANTICIPATE A TRIBALLY LED-
ASSESSING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THIS GRANT PROGRAM- AND SO BUT
WE THROUGH OUR PAST
CONSULTATIONS- WE DO HAVE SOME
EXAMPLES AND ANTICIPATE THE
TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT WILL COME
OUT OF THE FUNDS. I'M INCLUDING
DEVELOPING A CLIMATE AND
BIODIVERSITY TRAVEL MONITORING
PROGRAMS OF SUPPORTING PATHWAYS
FOR CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICANS
TO RESEARCH DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT TRADITIONAL ECOLOGICAL
KNOWLEDGE IS AND SHARING THOSE
KNOWLEDGE AS TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS HOW TO SUPPORT- YOU
KNOW THE FUTURE CULTURAL
PRACTITIONERS- AND THESE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. I WE ALSO
ANTICIPATE PROJECTS AROUND
CAPACITY BUILDING AND TECHNICAL
SUPPORT TWO X. CELEBRATE
EXPELLER EIGHT NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS CONSERVATION
BIODIVERSITY PROJECTS IN TRIBAL
LANDS AND COMMUNITIES- WE ALSO
ANTICIPATE PROJECTS THAT WILL
SUPPORT EXPLORE INCENTIVES FOR
TRIBAL PARTICIPATION AND OTHER
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH A LINK TO
THIRTIES AND IN THE END- AND ALL
THE OTHER PARTNERS THAT W.
SECRETARY HOT HANDSOME INTENDED
OPENING REMARKS I LASTLY WE
ANTICIPATE PROJECTS THAT
INCREASE COMMENCEMENT AND ACCESS
OPPORTUNITIES AND ANCESTRAL LAND
RETURN. THAT WILL DELIVER ON
CLIMATE IN BIOTECH THE BENEFITS
FOR CALIFORNIA. FILE IN OUR
CONSULTATIONS WE ALSO HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR THAT- A PROGRAM NEEDS. AND IN OVERCOMING SOME OF THE
BARRIERS THAT TRIBE DAVID
FACING- SOME OF THOSE BARRIERS
INCLUDE LIMITED TIME AND
CAPACITY FOR GRANT PROGRAMS OF
OVERLY COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAMS- THE NEED FOR TAILORED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- AND HAVING
FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR PLANNING
PROJECTS AND SO TRIBES IN
LEVERAGE LEVERAGE OTHER STATE
FUNDS AND FEDERAL FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THEIR PRIORITIES AND
NEEDS. IT'S A WE AT THIS IS THE
TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT WE
ANICIPATE COMING OUT OF THE
TRIBAL NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
PROGRAM. WILL WATER GRANT
PROGRAMS BE INCLUDED IN THE
OVERALL. BUNTINX CAN'T THE WATER
GRANT PROGRAM. THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- COOPER FOR WATER
GRANT PROGRAMS. SO OUR HOPE IS
THAT THIS PROGRAM KEY AND-
SUPPORT THE LEVERAGING OF OTHER
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS AND SO
THROUGH A TRIBALLY LED PROCESS
WORKING WITH TRIBAL LEADERS AND
SUPERVISORY COUNCIL AND
DETERMINING WHAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL BEST SUPPORT A
TRIBALLY IN THE NATION. THANK
YOU AND THEN- ONE OTHER
QUESTION- THAT- JUST TO- CLARIFY
THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SOB
THIS IS ALSO FUNDING THAT WOULD
BE ENCUMBERED FOR- USE OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS MR. AND SO IT
WOULD BE- USED FOR BOTH THE
PROCESS. FOR DETERMINING
PROJECTS AND POTENTIALLY ALSO
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROJECT IS THAT RIGHT YES. RIGHT
THANK YOU- THE LAST QUESTION THE
AGENDA- ASKS- HOWTHE- TROUBLE
CONSERVATION CORPS- ACCRUE
PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO. BE
IMPLEMENTED YES SO THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S IN YOUR OFFICE IN THE
TODAY- SHOWS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
PATIENT CO- THE WILL SUPPORT FOR
TRIBAL- AND THIS IS A NEW
PROGRAM THAT- THAT WILL IS IN
RESPONSE TO WHAT WE HEARD IN
CONSULTATION- WITH TRITON
DEVELOPING BOTH THE STRATEGIES.
AND THE THESE CORES WILL BE-
DEVELOPED IN PARTNERSHIP AND-
TRIBALLY LED TO BE TAILORED TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR TRIBAL
NATION PARTNERS AND- EARLY THEIR
CONSERVATION NEEDS WITH THE AT
SPECIFIC FOCUS ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. FOR SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD YOUTH- THAT
ARE SELECTED BY TRIBAL LEADERS
AND TRIBAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE TRAVEL. OF
THE BALLOT NO WORK DEVELOPMENT
AND TRAINING FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE- WITH PROJECTS THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS AND TRIBAL PRIORITIES-
THE MECHANICS OF THESE WILL BE
VERY SALAS SIMILAR TO LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
AND REGIONAL CORPS CREWS BUT
WILL ALSO BE- TRIBALLY LED AND
TO TAILOR TO FEET FIT THE
SPECIFIC TRIBES AND THE CREWS
THAT WILL BE SUPPORTING THE- ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU ANY OTHER. THANK
YOU TAX. I HAVE A COUPLE FORM IN
REGARDS TO THE L. A. ILLS OF
ADMINISTRATIONS NOT PROVIDING
MEASURABLE GOALS FOR THE THIRTY
BY THIRTY IF WE DON'T HAVE ANY
MEASURABLE GOALS HOW DO WE KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET TO OUR END WE
HAVE AN UPDATE THE NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET BEFORE WE GO THROUGH TWO
YEARS. OF THIS FUNDING. JENNIFER
NORRIS CALIFORNIA TO RESOURCE
AGENCY AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. OF THIRTY BY THIRTY
ITSELF IS A MEASURABLE GOAL THAT
WE ARE ACTIVELY TRACKING AND WE
WILL BE- FOLLOWING HOW THESE
FUNDS ARE SPENT- WHETHER
THEY'RE- MOVING FORWARD ON
ACQUISITIONS OR EASEMENTS WHICH
PART OF STATE. AND I WHICH OF
OUR OBJECTIVES THEY DO DRIVE ON
SO WE'LL BE TRACKING THOSE. WHO
GET THE PAGES WILL GO ALONG AND
ENCOURAGE THE WCB FOR THE DESERT
CONSERVATION. IN MY DISTRICT
PRETTY MUCH IS A DESERT AND I'M
BIG CONCERN WITH THE JOSHUA
TREES. AND WE'RE GOING TO GET AN
UPDATE PRETTY SOON IF IT'S GOING
TO BE IN DANGER OR NOT. I'M
WORRIED ABOUT THIS HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS MAKING SURE THAT
THEY SET ASIDE A PROPERTY. THAT
WE CAN STILL DEVELOP WITH INDIA.
INDIA OF KINSA JOSHUA TREES THAT
I FEEL IS NOT IN DANGER. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF TO BOND
INTERVIEWING LIKE KNOW IF THAT
WAS A QUESTION. WE CAN HAVE
DIRECTOR BOTTOM I. JUMP IF THERE
IS A- ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M-
CUTELY AWARE OF ALL THINGS
WESTERN JOSHUA TREE ARE SEPARATE
COMMISSION WILL BE DELIBERATING
ON THAT IN JUNE. I DO THINK IT'S
SEPARATE FROM THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENT TO A REALLY
IMPORTANT. EMERGING AND NEW
ENTITY TO HELP CONSERVATION IN
THE DESERT BUT I'M AVAILABLE- AT
YOUR OFFICES REQUEST TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU OFFLINE ON ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ABOUT JOSH WITH
TRADITIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. GREAT WELL THANK YOU FOR THE-
MISTER BENNETT WE GAVE YOU A
LITTLE TIME YOU CAME UP WITH
ANOTHER QUESTION. I THINK THAT
MY COLLEAGUE JUST BEAT ME TO THE
PUNCH ON THE- PUSHING THE
BUTTON- THIS. GUY I WOULD WANT
TO COMPETE WITH THE MCGINNIS ON
JEOPARDY RIGHT- NOT A
COMPETITION. PLEASE I WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF PILOT
PROGRAMS IT SEEMS THAT IF WE
IDENTIFY PILOT PROGRAMS WE WANT
START AND THAT WE SHOULD ALWAYS
HAVE AS A OVERALL ARCHING POLICY
pSO THAT'S GOING TO COME UP MORE
THAN ONCE HERE SO I WON'T REPEAT
IT OVER AND OVER AGAIN BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT HAPPEN-
IT AND COMBINED WITH THAT- I
THINK WE CONSISTENTLY GET RID BE
SUGGESTIONS FROM ALEJO. THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE- MEASUREMENTS GOALS
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT IS IT HOW DO
WE EVALUATE THE SUCCESS OF THE
PROGRAM LIKE CENTER AND THAT
WOULD BE VERY VALUABLE- WHO
RATHER THAN HEARING THAT EACH
TIME AND HOPE. I COULD COME UP
WITH A WAY TO SORT OF A STAB
SOME. SORT OF YOU KNOW SOME
PROGRAM AROUND THAT THAT WHEN
THE BUDGET REQUEST COMES IN THAT
THAT IS JUST ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT IS- DRESSED- STRIKES ME AS
AS AN APPROPRIATE WAY YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT. THE QUESTION NEEDS TO
BE ANSWERED WHAT IS YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE THE MEASUREMENT TOOLS
OR ONE OF THE GOALS ARE ONE OF
THE WAYS THAT WE COULD PUT HOW
CAN WE EVALUATE WHETHER THIS HAS
BEEN. THE FACT OF- USE OF THESE
DOLLARS SO- THAT'S- YOU KNOW
GOING TO CONNECT. BEING REPEATED
I WILL REPEAT THAT THE REST OF
THE DAY TODAY BUT THOSE ARE TWO
THINGS I'D LIKE TO. TO HOPEFULLY
HAVE BECOME OVER ARCHING THINGS
FOR THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT AND
THAT- BRINGS US TO THE
CONCLUSION OF ISSUE ONE. WILL
SHUFFLE SOME OF THE FOLKS AT
THE- AT AT THE TABLE AND-
CONTINUE WITH THE ISSUE NUMBER
TWO A- DRESSING THE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF EXTREME HEAT. DEPUTY SECRETARY WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. SHUFFLING MY
PAPERS THANK YOU TAKE IT TO YOUR
- OKAY WELL AGAIN I'M A HANSEN I
SERVICE THE SECRETARY FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE AT THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY- AND
OUR AGENCY IS STATUTORILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR COORDINATING
CALIFORNIA'S UPDATE TO OUR STATE
ADAPTATION. HE THIS YEAR WE DID
IT IN. TIGHTKNIT PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH GIVEN THEIR RESILIENCE
PROGRAM JUST. GIVE ME A MOMENT
INTRODUCED YOURSELF GREAT
SERVICE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND I'M NEW IN TARA
KEY I'M DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH. SO I THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION TO PRESENT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL FOR
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION.
EXTREMELY SATISFIED- I'M GONNA
PROVIDE SOME BACKGROUND ON THE
IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FUNDING PROPOSAL WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EXTREME
HEAT ACTION PLAN. AND THEN A NEW
IN TARA WILL PROVIDE. THE SET
ASIDE. SO ON ON SORT OF BASICS
FOR HEAT IMPACTS JUST FOR
PUTTING US ON THE SAME PAGE BEST
AVAILABLE CLIMATE SCIENCE
PROJECTS THAT EXTREME HEAT WILL
IMPACT EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE
OPPOSING WRECKS RISKS TO EVERY
REGION AND EVERY SECTOR. EXTREME
HEAT THREATENS CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES NATURAL SYSTEMS AND
ECONOMY IT ALSO PROPOSES. POSES
PROFOUNDLY DISPROPORTIONATE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US. ADDRESSING
THESE INTERCONNECTED COMPLEX
IMPACTS OF HEAT REQUIRES A
DIVERSE SUITE OF ACTIONS AND
RESOURCES AND AN ALL OF
GOVERNMENT APPROACH. ANNUAL
TEMPERATURES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
ALREADY EXCEEDED ONE DEGREES
FAHRENHEIT WITH SOME AREAS
EXCEEDING TWO DEGREES FAHRENHEIT. DURING THE SPRING HEATWAVE
EARLIER- IN THE SPRING OF LONG
BEACH REACHED A HIGH OF A
HUNDRED AND ONE DEGREES BREAKING
ITS LAST DAILY RECORD SET BACK
IN APRIL OF TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH
A HIGH OF NINETY TWO. LAST YEAR
WE EXPECT THE HOTTEST SUMMER ON
RECORD WITH DEATH VALLEY SETTING
AN UNFORTUNATE WORLD RECORD FOR
THE HOTTEST MEASURE TEMPERATURE
IN HISTORY. HITTING A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY DEGREES IN ULY. AND
FRESNO SAW OVER SIXTY DAYS ABOVE
ONE HUNDRED DEGREES. THE DAILY
MAXIMUM AVERAGE TEMPERATURE
WHICH IS AN INDICATOR OF EXTREME
TEMPERATURE SHIFTS IS EXPECTED
TO RISE BETWEEN FOUR POINT FOUR
AND FIVE POINT EIGHT DEGREES
FAIR RIGHT BY TWENTY FIFTY. FIVE
POINT SIX AND EIGHT POINT EIGHT
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT BY TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED. GET A GOING TO THE
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN NOW-
THE ACTUAL PLAN WAS DEVELOPED AS
PART OF THE STATE'S TWENTY
TWENTY ONE UPDATE TO
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE ADAPTATION
STRATEGY IN RECOGNITION OF A
REAL NEED FOR AN UPDATED.
INTEGRATED APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING EXTREME HEAT ACROSS
STATE AGENCIES. THE PLAN THE
PLAN PROVIDES A STRATEGIC AND
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF STATE
ACTIONS TO ADAPT AND BUILD
RESILIENCE TO EXTREME HEAT. IT
OUTLINES ARE ALL OF GOVERNMENT
APPROACH TO MITIGATING THE
HEALTH ECONOMIC CULTURAL
ECOLOGICAL AND SOCIAL IMPACTS OF
INCREASING TEMPERATURES. AND THE
ACTIONS INCLUDED PLAN WERE
DEVELOPED AND REFINED BY OVER A
DOZEN AGENCIES AND OVER FORTY OF
THEIR DEPARTMENTS COMMISSIONS
COUNCILS BOARD OFFICES THE
CONSERVANCY'S ALL OUR PARTNERS.
IT WAS DEVELOPED THROUGH
EXTENSIVE PUBLIC INPUT OVER THE
COURSE OF LAST YEAR. AND THEN
PUT STATE THE PROGRAMS INCLUDED
AND HE'D SET ASIDE PROPOSAL IT
ALSO DEP. THE IN AN CONTACT OF
THE EXTREME HEAT ACTIONS. AND
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT SHAPE THE
EXPEDIENT PLAN IS HOW IT IS
ORGANIZED WHICH IS AROUND FOUR
ACTION TRACKS SO WE HEARD FROM
OUR ENGAGEMENT THAT THERE IS
REALLY FOR AREAS WHERE STATE.
ACTION AND COMMITMENT WOULD BE
MOST HELPFUL THE FIRST IS AND
BUILDING PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
NOTIFICATION WHICH WILL INCREASE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE HEALTH
THREATS AND PREPARATION FOR
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS. THE SECOND
AREA OF FOCUS IS ON
STRENGTHENING COMMUNITY SERVICES
IN RESPONSE WHICH ARE ACTIONS TO
INCREASE. CASSIDY REDUCE SIX AN
INCREASE PROTECTIONS FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS TO
EXTREMELY. THIRD AREA OF FOCUS
FOR STATE ACTION IS INCREASING
RESILIENCE OF OUR BUILT
ENVIRONMENT WHICH WILL REDUCE
HE'S PETE RISKS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION ENERGY AND
BUILDING SECTORS AND FINALLY THE
FOURTH AREA OF FOCUS AND ACTION
TRACK IS UTILIZING NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS TO COLMOBIL
COMMUNITIES AND BUILD RESILIENCE
OF NATURAL SYSTEMS TO INCREASING
TEMPERATURES THAT ARE ON THEIR
WAY. THAT ARE HERE AND ON THEIR
WAY- SO THE EXTREME HEAT ACTION
PLAN ALSO IDENTIFIES SIX AREAS
OF NEAR TERM FOCUS WHICH ARE
REFLECTED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET PROPOSALS
INCLUDING THE EXTREME HEAT
ACTION PLAN- THESE INCLUDE.
IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE PUBLIC
HEALTH MONITORING SYSTEM TO
IDENTIFY HEAT ILLNESS EVENTS
EARLY TO MONITOR TRENDS AND
TRACK ILLNESSES TO INTERVENE AND
PREVENT FURTHER HARM.
ACCELERATING THE READINESS AND
PROTECTION OF COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED BY EXTREME HEAT
INCLUDING THROUGH COOLING
SCHOOLS AND HOMES SUPPORTING
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS AND
EXPANDING NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
. PROTECTING VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THROUGH CODES
STANDARDS AND REGULATIONS
EXPANDING ECONOMIC ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND BUILDING A
CLIMATE SMART WORKFORCE THAT CAN
OPERATE UNDER AND ADDRESS
EXTREME HEAT. INCREASING PUBLIC
AWARENESS TO REDUCE RISKS POSED
BY EXTREME HEAT AND PROTECTING
NATURAL WORKING LANDS ECOSYSTEMS
AND BIODIVERSITY FROM THE
IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT SO I'LL
NOW HAND IT OFF TO MY COLLEAGUE
EVEN TARA TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE SET ASIDE PROPOSAL.
THANKS CURO AMANDA AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
SO- BEFORE I GET INTO THE SET
ASIDE JUST FOR CONTEXT YOU KNOW
IN LIGHT OF THE IMPACTS- THAT
AMANDA WENT THROUGH AND GIVEN
THE CROSS CUTTING IMPACTS OF
EXTREME HEAT. AT LAST YEAR'S
HISTORIC CLIMATE BUDGET
COMMITTED EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
TO ADDRESSING EXTREME HEAT OF
THAT THREE HUNDRED MILLION OF
THESE FUNDS WERE SET ASIDE TO
ADVANCE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
STATE'S EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN
WHICH ON MONDAY JUST WENT
THROUGH. AS AMANDA MENTIONED THE
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN
INCLUDES AND IDENTIFIES THOSE
AREAS OF NEAR TERM FOCUS AND I
JUST WANT TO KNOW BEFORE I GO
THROUGH WHAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
SET ASIDE PACKAGE. BUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET FOR-
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE INCLUDES
A NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL AND
COMPLEMENTARY FUNDING- PROPOSALS
THAT FILL OUT AND ADDRESS THOSE
AREAS OF NEAR TERM FOCUS THAT
AREN'T COVERED IN THE EXTREME
HEAT SATISFIED. AND HAPPY TO
TALK THROUGH THAT MORE IF THERE
ARE QUESTIONS ON THE CONNECTIONS
BUT JUST A NOTE OF CONTEXT THERE
. SO THE EXTREME HEAT SET ASIDE
INCLUDES PROGRAMS FROM SEVEN
STATE ENTITIES ACROSS THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH. CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AGAIN. DEMONSTRATING
HOW THE CROSSCUTTING NATURE OF
THIS PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT. SO THE
SATISFIED IS ORGANIZED AROUND
FOUR CATEGORIES THE FIRST ONE
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO ACCELERATE
READINESS AND PROTECT
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED BY
EXTREME HEAT. INCLUDING THROUGH
COOLING SCHOOLS SUPPORTING
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS AND
EXPANDING NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS. THIS INCLUDES FIFTY
MILLION TO CAL FIRE TO COOL
SCHOOLS BY WORKING WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND OTHERS TO FOCUS
THE URBAN AND COMMUNITY FORESTRY
PROGRAM GRANT FUNDS TOWARDS THE
GREENING OF SCHOOLYARDS. ALSO
INCLUDED IN THIS CATEGORY IS A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION
PROPOSED TO GO TO THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS BY
PROVIDING GRANTS TO COMMUNITIES
SEEKING TO BUILD. FOR GREAT
EXISTING BUILDINGS AND SUPPORT
PROGRAMS ASSOCIATED WITH
BUILDING COMMUNITY SOCIAL
STRUCTURE. S. CATEGORY OF THE
SENATE SIDE IS TO PROTECT
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
ECOSYSTEMS FROM EXTREME HEAT
RISKS THIS CATEGORY INCLUDES FOR
FORTY THREE POINT ONE MILLION.
THE FIRST SET OF INVESTMENTS
PROPOSED THROUGH THIS CATEGORY
ARE TO ENHANCE PROTECTIONS FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS INCLUDING
WORKERS IN HIGH RISK INDUSTRIES
AND INDIVIDUALS AND LICENSED
CARE FACILITIES. THIS INCLUDES
TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS DIVISION OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH.
AND WILL BUILD UPON AND EXPAND
ITS TARGETED OUTREACH AND
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS TO PROTECT
WORKERS FROM HEAT RELATED
ILLNESSES THIS WILL BE COUPLED
WITH TARGETED ENFORCEMENT BEFORE
AND DURING PERIODS OF HIGH RISK.
IN ITS DONE THERE'S ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION PROPOSED FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH'S
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH BRANCH WHICH
WILL CONDUCT OUTREACH TO
EMPLOYERS TO INFORM THEM ABOUT
EXTREME HEAT RISKS IN INDOOR AND
OUTDOOR SETTINGS APPLICABLE
REGULATIONS AND RESOURCES FOR
ASSISTANCE IN MINIMIZING RISK.
THIS CATEGORY INCLUDES AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CENTER FOR HEALTH
CARE QUALITY TO PROVIDE OUTREACH
OVERSIGHT EDUCATION AND TRAINING
ABOUT EXTREME HEAT AND IT'S A
FAX. TO THE SURVEYORS OF LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES. LASTLY IN
THIS CATEGORY THERE'S EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION PROPOSED FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO PROVIDE TARGETED
INFORMATION TO PREVENT HEAT
RELATED ILLNESS FOR ITS LICENSED
RESIDENTIAL AND CHILD CARE.
FACILITIES BUT LACKS THE
RESOURCES TO ADEQUATELY PREVENT
HEAT IMPACTS. IN ADDITION IN
THIS CATEGORY THERE'S ADDITION
THERE'S ALSO FUNDING TO PROTECT
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
ECOSYSTEMS AND BIODIVERSITY.
THERE'S PROPOSED TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATIONS TO
SUPPORT SMALL UNDERSERVED FARMS
AND LARGE DISADVANTAGED URBAN
CENTERS THROUGH INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND OUTREACH. IN ADDITION
THERE'S FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
FOR CDFA TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT TO HANDLE
UNEXPECTED ANIMAL MORTALITY DUE
TO EXTREME HEAT AS WELL AS
PROVIDE ORIGIN INSPECTION
SERVICES TO ENSURE THAT PASS
THAT MAY THRIVE UNDER INCREASED
HE CONDITIONS ARE EXCLUDED FROM
ENTERING THE STATE. THE THIRD OF
FOUR CATEGORIES IN THIS SET
ASIDE INCLUDES TWENTY MILLION TO
INCREASE PUBLIC AWARENESS TO
REDUCE RISKS POSED BY EXTREME
HEAT WITH THE PROPOSED TWENTY
MILLION TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH TO
DELIVER A PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN WHOSE KEY COMPONENTS
INCLUDE ENGAGING A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS. AND THIS
CAMPAIGN WILL INCLUDE DEVELOPING
TAILORED AWARENESS MATERIALSAND
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
MEDIASPECIALIZING IN IN
LANGUAGE AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT CONTENT. AND FINALLY
THE FOURTH CATEGORY INCLUDES
SEVENTEEN MILLION TO EXPAND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND BUILD A
CLIMATE SMART WORKFORCE THE CAN
OPERATE UNDER AN ADDRESS EXTREME
HEAT. THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO
DEVELOP AND EXPAND HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS TO ADDRESS
EXTREME HEAT. THAT CONCLUDES MY
OVERVIEW OF WHAT IS INCLUDED IN
THE EXTREME HEAT SET ASIDE
PACKAGE AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. HEARTMATE LEFT TO
HEAR FROM A ALEJO. I THANK YOU
CHAIR- AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT UNITS ROW AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SAID TODAY WE HAVE A FEW INITIAL
OVER ARCHING COMMENTS- TO THIS
PROPOSED PACKAGE. THE OVERALL WE
FIND THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE
IS COMPRISED OF A DIVERSE RANGE
OF ACTIVITIES RANGING FROM
DIRECT RELIEF FOR EXTREME HAVE
THAT KEY EVENTS TO EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS I WORK
PLACES. HOWEVER WHILE SOME OF
THESE ACTIVITIES MAY HAVE MERIT
IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER THESE
PROPOSALS ADDRESS THE MOST
IMPORTANT CONCERNS ADDRESSED-
ASSOCIATED WITH EXTREME HEAT.
AND WHETHER THIS COMBINATION OF
A PROPOSALS IS THE MOST
STRATEGIC WAY TO ADDRESS SUCH
PRIORITIES. THIS PACKAGE IS
INTENDED TO ALIGN WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RECENTLY
FINALIZED EXTREME HEAT ACTION
PLAN WHICH DOES INCLUDE SEVERAL
GOALS. HOWEVER THE PLAN LACKS A
CLEAR STRATEGY AND MEASURABLE
GOALS AND IT MAKES WHICH MAKES
IT DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE PROPOSED PACKAGE. IS
THE BEST APPROACH TO ADDRESS THE
MOST PRESSING CONCERNS RELATED
TO EXTREME HEAT. IN ADDITION WE
FIND THAT. THOUGH IT FUNDS A
WIDE RANGE OF ACTIVITIES AT IT
IS LIMITED IN SOME IMPORTANT
AREAS SUCH AS- DIRECT HEAT
REDUCTION ACTIVITIES- AND
RESEARCH. FIRST WITH RESPECT TO
DIRECT HEAT REDUCTION
INTERVENTIONS THE PACKAGE IS NOT
INCLUDE SOME CRITICAL BUILDING
LEVEL INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS AIR
CONDITIONING INSTALLATIONS AND
ENERGY EFFICIENCY RETROFITS. IN
PLACES WHERE PEOPLE SPEND THE
MOST OF THEIR DATES SUCH AS
THEIR HOMES SCHOOLS WORKPLACES.
AND THESE TYPES OF INTERVENTIONS
COULD PROVIDE DIRECT RELIEF FROM
EXTREME HEAT I AM ESPECIALLY FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHO MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO MODIFY THEIR
SURROUNDINGS WITHOUT STATE
ASSISTANCE. SECOND ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR RESEARCH MIGHT BE
WARRANTED ADAM DID BECAUSE MUCH
UNCERTAINTY REMAINS ABOUT WHICH
POLICY INTERVENTIONS ARE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO REDUCE
THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS. OF EXTREME
HEAT- FURTHER RESEARCH SUCH AS
PILOT PROGRAMS RESEARCH AND
EVALUATION- COULD HELP PROVIDE
MORE INFORMATION AND SUCH AS
WHICH ACTIVITIES ARE THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO. ADDRESS
EXTREME HEAT I AM AND WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
AT REACHING VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. THE LEGISLATURE
ALSO MAY WANT TO CONSIDER AB.
WHICH TYPES OF ACTIVITIES ARE
MORE SUITED FOR ONE TIME FUNDING
AND SOME TYPES OF ACTIVITIES ARE
MORE APPROPRIATE FOR ONE TIME
FUNDING THAN OTHERS SUCH AS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS PILOT
PROGRAMS AND RESEARCH I AM
BECAUSE THE BENEFITS OF THESE
ACTIVITIES. AB REMAIN AFTER THE
FUNDING ENDS FOR EXAMPLE THE
GREENING SCHOOLYARDS PROPOSAL
AND IS STUDENTS TEACHERS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS CAN. AND THE
FAT FROM SHADES THAT BY MORE
SHADED SCHOOLYARDS AND
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDORS AYE
WELL BEYOND THE FUNDING PERIOD
IN. AN CONTRAST USING ONE TIME
FUNDING I AM FOR. AT LIMITED
TERM STAFFING AND SERVICES MIGHT
BE LESS EFFECTIVE BECAUSE THEY
ONLY PROVIDE BENEFITS DURING THE
FUNDING PERIOD. I'M FOR INSTANCE
THE PROPOSED ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES UNDER CAL OSHA LIKELY
WOULD NEED TO BE CONDUCTED ON AN
ONGOING BASIS FOR A TO BE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE. AND ADDITIONALLY
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT AT. THE
MAJORITY OF THE PACKAGE IS
CONSIDERED EXEMPT THAT EXCLUDED
EXCLUDABLE FROM STYLE BUT EIGHT
ABOUT EIGHTY MILLION IS SUBJECT
TO THE LIMIT SO. GIVEN THAT THE
STYLE WILL CONTINUE TO CONSTRAIN
THE STATE'S BUDGET AT. OPTIONS
THIS YEAR AT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER SHIFTING MORE
FUNDING ADD TO SALAS CRITICAL
ACTIVITIES. AT WE ALSO KNOW AS
THE ADMINISTRATION MENTIONED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO DOES
INCLUDE SOME OTHER EXTREME HEAT
RELATED PROPOSALS. OUTSIDE OF
THIS PACKAGE SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
BUDGET DOES INCLUDE TEN MILLION
FOR IT THAT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
COLLECT AND ANALYZE REAL TIME
DATA. ON THE IMPACTS OF THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF EXTREMES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE INCLUDING EXTREME
HEAT. AND I THIS IS ALSO IN
ADDITION TO THE M. THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION AND THAT THAT
LEGISLATURE APPROVED AND THAT
KIND OF PACKAGE LAST YEAR FOR
EXTREME HE ACTIVITIES. THE
LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WANT TO.
CONSIDER THE FUNDING PROVIDE SO.
THAT SORRY THE LEGISLATURE MON
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER ALL OF
THESE KIND OF- FUNDING PROVIDED
FOR ALL RELEVANT HEAT RELATED.
PROPOSALS TO INSURANCE
APPROACHES ADAM STRATEGIC
COMPREHENSIVE AND NOT
DUPLICATIVE. AND FINALLY THE
PROPOSED A PACKAGE CURRENTLY
DOES NOT INCLUDE A PLAN TO
REPORT ON THE OUTCOMES THAT ARE
ACHIEVED WITH THE FUNDING. M.
AND NOT ONLY WITH SUCH REPORTING
BANK KEEP THE ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNTABLE AND TO MEET THE
INTENDED GOALS OF THE PACKAGE
BY. I WOULD ALSO HELP THE
LEGISLATURE CONDUCTED ITS
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS M. AND ALSO
COULD HELP AT THE LEGISLATURE.
ON FUTURE POLICY AND FUNDING
DECISIONS REGARDING EXTREME HEAT
STRATEGIES AT TO ASSESS WHICH
APPROACHES HAVE BEEN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND WHICH PER-
PROGRAMS MIGHT WARRANT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE
FUTURE. AND SO THAT CONCLUDES
OUR COMMENTS WERE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU PRETTY
SURE THAT'S ALL. THAT WAS A LOT
- I THANK YOU FOR A- BEING CUT
COMPREHENSIVE IN YOUR- ANALYSIS
OF DOES SAID- THE- DEPARTMENTS
HAVE ANY COMMENTS THINKING YES
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO CLIMATE
BUDGET TO PROVIDE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND OVER TWO
YEARS.BUT LIKE THE NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS PACKAGE WOULD ALSO
KNOW THAT THE PROGRAMS DO HAVE
EXTENDED AVAILABILITY WITH MOST
PROGRAMS HAVING TWO TO THREE
YEARS TO ENCUMBER FINDS. AND
THEN AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED THERE
ARE MANY OTHER COMPLEMENTARY
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO WE REALLY
SEE THIS SET ASIDE AS PROVIDING
FILLING SOME GAPS. AND
DEMONSTRATING THE HOLISTIC
APPROACH THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS TAKING TO ADDRESSING EXTREME
HEAT AND THEN FINALLY WOULD ALSO
REITERATE THAT THE EXTREME HEAT
EXTREME HEAT. PLAN WAS RECENTLY
RELEASED SO THIS PROP PACKAGE
PRIORITIZES FUNDING ON A SHORT
TERM BASIS TO JUMPSTART THE
WHILE PROVIDING TIME TO EVALUATE
THE NEEDS FOR ON GOING FUNDING.
THANK YOU- SO- IS IT INTENDED
THAT- P. R. KIND OF BE THE MAIN
AGENCY THAT IS COORDINATING. ALL
OF THIS. YES THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT QUESTION- SO OPR
THROUGH OUR INTEGRATED CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY
PROGRAM THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
THROUGH A DIRECTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH SENATE BILL
TWO FORTY SIX DOES SERVE AS THE
STATE'S HUBFOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND ADAPTATION POLICY
ALIGNMENT AND COORDINATION
IMPORTANTLY ACROSS AND WITH OUR
AGENCY PARTNERS. BUT ALSO WITH
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS ON THE GROUND
WHO ARE REALLY LEADING UP
IMPLEMENTATION SO IN CONTEXT OF
OUR ROLE IN STATE GOVERNMENT AS
THAT PUB FOR RECORD NATION AN
ALIGNMENT- WE ARE ALSO LOOKING
FORWARD TO IMPLEMENTING AN
EXTREME HEAT- PROGRAMS GRANT
PROGRAM IN THIS COMING BUDGET
YEAR GIVEN- DECISIONS THE
AGREEMENT AND LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. SO WITH ALL OF THAT
CONTEXT IN TERMS OF OUR ROLE AS
THAT COORDINATING HUB AND GIVEN
THE ADDITIONAL CAPACITY WE WILL
HAVE- IN SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING
EXTREME HEAT THROUGH OUR NEW
GRANT PROGRAM WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO COORDINATE AND
ALIGN EFFORTS ACROSS STATE
AGENCIES ON EXTREME HEAT. THANK
YOU AND- THIS QUESTION MAY- COPY
APPROPRIATE FOR A CAL FIRE AND
WE'VE GOT- SOMEBODY EITHER HERE
IN THE ROOM OR A ROOM UP.
AVAILABLE REMOTELY- THE- I URBAN
GREENING FUNDING IS- AS DIRECTED
SCHOOLS FOR SOME OF THE URBAN
GREENING OF FUNDING IS DIRECTED
AT SCHOOLS ON- CAN YOU DISCUSS
THAT MORE AUNT- WHY WOULD THAT
NOT BE FUNDED WITH. PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING. SO I'M I'M HAPPY
TO ELABORATE ON THE URBAN
FORESTRY PROGRAM HAS IN THE PAST
BEEN FUNDED BY BOTH THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
AND THE GENERAL FUND COVER AND
NOT A PROP NINETY EXPERTS I'M
HAPPY TO. I'D TAKE THAT QUESTION
BACK TO MY EDUCATION
COUNTERPARTS GREAT THANK YOU-
AND THEN- WHAT ASPECT SAYS
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
CONSTRUCTION. THINGS LIKE SMART
GRID AND BATTERY STORAGE- OF.
HOW HOW DO WE INTEGRATE THOSE
INTO- EXTREME HEAT MITIGATION.
SO HAVE I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
COLLEAGUE HERE FROM THE-
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND
HE'S PREPARED TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION FOR EIGHT ELEVEN TAKE
MY FEET. WELCOME THANK YOU
TWENTY CHAIRED MEMBERS- RAPHAEL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD HYDRO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS PROGRAM- SPEAKING
TO THE QUESTION- REALLY GOING TO
HAVE TO GO BACK AND SAY- I
APPRECIATE BEING HERE WITH MATCH
RESEARCH AGENCY PARTNERS AND- PR
BECAUSE OF THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. YOU KNOW WE
DON'T WANT TO BE SORT OF AN
AFTERTHOUGHT AND- TALKING ABOUT.
NOT TO RESOURCES AND CLIMATE- F.
AB THIRTY TWO PASSED A LONG TIME
AGO. TO GET CONVERSATION GOING
ON WORKFORCE BUT HERE WE ARE
SITTING AT THE TABLE UP FRONT.
TALK ABOUT WORKFORCE AND SO OUR
APPROACH TO IDENTIFYING- H. I.
T. P. HIERO TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS IS TO. HAVE A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS. THESE
ARE JUST SOME PRELIMINARY IDEAS
WE HAD AS FAR AS LIKE WHO WOULD
WE PARTNER WITH AND WE KNOW- H.
BACK FOR A COUPLE CONSTRUCTION
OUTDOOR WORKERS ARE AFFECTED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE AND- DIFFICULT.
REQUEST WE THAT. YOU KNOW THE
GREATEST THEY NEED TO BE
HARDENED- RESPONSE TO EXTREME
HEAT. AND YOU KNOW ALL THE
QUICKENING WOULD NEED TO BE
CHANGED OUT AND NEW TECHNOLOGIES
WE NEED TO BE ADAPTED. SUCH AS-
YOU KNOW SMART GRIDS AND-
BATTERY STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES
BUT- SOME OF THE EXISTING
INDUSTRIES- CONSTRUCTION
ELECTRICIANS THOSE OF THE TRADE
THAT WOULD BE WORKING WITH THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE PARTNERSHIPS
IN THOSE AREAS SO. WE BEGUN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT- THESE
ARE IDEAS AND CONCEPTS THAT WE
WOULD- IDENTIFY. POTENTIAL
PARTNERS AND EVEN DO OUTREACH
BUT IT WOULD BE THROUGH A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS THAT
WE WOULD- ADMINISTER THESE
FUNDS. THEN WE WOULD DO SO- YOU
KNOW. AND WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES AGENCY AND
OTHER PARTNERS TO IDENTIFY THOSE
PROJECTS. THANK YOU AND I-
TANGENTIALLY AT I DON'T THINK WE
GIVE MUCH THOUGHT TO- THE IMPACT
OF EXTREME HEAT ON THE WORK
FORCE- AND PARTICULARLY IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WHERE MUCH
OF THAT WORK IS DONE OUTDOORS-
WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT HOW WE-
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM THE IMPACT
OF. OF EXTREME HEAT AS WE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. AND CHECK YOUR
BEING HERE WE DON'T TYPICALLY
SEE HERE AND IN STEP THREE SO
THAT'S A NICE CHANGE OF PACE
FORCE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT-
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
QUESTIONS OF YOUR OWN I KNOW YOU
HAVE FOR- ON BEHALF OF THE THIS
RIVAS AS WELL. THANK YOU CHAIR I
WILL I WILL START QUESTIONS FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROB RIVAS- WHO
WAS UNABLE TO ATTEND- SO HER
OFFICE- REACHED OUT TO ME AND
ASKED IF I COULD ASK THESE
QUESTIONS SO THE FIRST ONE FOR
CAL FIRE- BUT I KNOW YOU
RESPND. ON CALIFORNIA'S BEHALF
BEFORE SO PERHAPS YOU WILL- AND
THE URBAN FORESTRY- GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS PROGRAM FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS- THAT'S OUT
THERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
AUTHORED- AB FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
AND TWENTY NINETEEN AND THIS
YEAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON-
HAS AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY SIX OF
BOTH BILLS SEEK TO SUPPORT
SCHOOL GREETING- GIVEN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY HAVE
DETAILS ON OF THE GREENING UP
PROJECTS THERE- WILL CAL FIRE
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCORPORATE TO PROVISIONS OF AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY SIX INTO THIS
PROPOSAL. MAYBE I COULD TAKE A
FIRST CRACK AT THAT AGAIN-
TURNED TO COLLEAGUES FROM CAL
FIRE- TO- IF EITHER ADD TO IT
OR- GOD FORBID CORRECT THE
RECORD- SO I THINK THE IDEA HERE
IS- IT WOULD BE REALLY IMPORTANT
TO US TO THE EXTENT THAT THOSE
BILLS ARE- MOVING FORWARD AND-
END UP SORT OF. SORT OF SETTING
A FRAMEWORK FOR US THAT THE WORK
THAT WE DO TO GREEN SCHOOLYARDS
AT THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM ABSOLUTELY ALIGNS WITH
THOSE EFFORTS SO- MAKE THE TOP
LINE ANSWER IS YES WE WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE SURE THAT IF THOSE BILLS
MOVE FORWARD WE WOULD PARTNER.
PLEASE CORRECT THE RECORD OR
WEIGH IN WITH ADDITIONAL DETAILS
PARTNERS THAT CALIFORNIA NEED BE
. THE MORNING- MACKEY REISMAN
DEPUTY DIRECTOR RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT WITH CAL FIRE AND-
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT WE
SUPPORT THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO- TO WORK WITH COLLEAGUES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT OUR PROGRAM
ALIGNS- WITH ANY OTHER ADDITIONS
THAT NEED BE A WE DO BY STATUTE
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO. IMPLEMENT
THIS PROGRAM ACCORDINGLY SO
WE'RE- WE'RE HAPPY TO
POTENTIALLY RECEIVE THE FUNDS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE WHATEVER NEED BE IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE WE DO MINIST
ADMINISTER THEM APPROPRIATELY
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU I'M
SURE SOME REMEMBER RIVAS WILL
APPRECIATE HEARING THAT- SHE
HAS- DONE SOME VERY. EXTENSIVE
AND AN EFFECTIVE WORK ON THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF- OF THE HEAT AND
THE RESILIENCY THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE OUT THERE SO- APPRECIATE
THAT THIS QUESTION IS FOR- OPR-
AND THE BCP ALLOCATES TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS OUT OF THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR OPR TO
LAUNCH A PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN- AND- THE QUESTION FROM
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHY ONLY
FOCUS ON PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
NOT. ACTUAL PROJECTS THAT WILL
PREVENT EXTREME HEAT EVENTS OR
MITIGATE AND ORDERED MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS- AN INCREASE IN
FUNDING COULD PROVIDE- P. R.
WITH FUNDING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DO COMMUNITY
EXTREME. ACTION HE ACTION PLANS
AND TO FUND COMMUNITY COOLING
PROJECTS CAN YOU HELP US WITH
THAT PLEASE YES ABSOLUTELY. SO-
YEAH AS WITH MANY THE TWO
MILLION INCLUDE IN THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE SET ASIDE IS FOCUSED ON
PUBLIC AWARENESS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HEARD-
CONSISTENTLY IN OUR ENGAGEMENT
WITH PARTNERS AND STAKEHOLDERS
OVER THE LAST YEAR- AS WE'RE
DEVELOPING THE HEAT ACTION PLAN.
WAS THE NEED TO REALLY BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS OF
EXTREME HEAT AND ALSO WHAT TO DO
IN THE EVENT OF YOU KNOW EXTREME
HEAT EVENTS- IN. IN THAT MOMENT
SO THAT FUNDING THE TWENTY
MILLION IS SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED
AT HELPING COMMUNITIES BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW TO PREPARE AND
HOW TO RESPOND WITH EXTREME
HEAT. NOW AS WAS NOTED IN THE
QUESTION THERE ALSO IS NEED TO
DEVELOP- LOCAL PLANS EXTREME
HEAT ACTION PLANS- AND ALSO TO
DRIVE INVESTMENT INTO ACTUAL
PROJECTS ON THE GROUND AS WELL.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE AT OPR ARE
LOOKING AT OUR- EXTREME HEAT AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE GRANT
PROGRAM THAT. THAT CAME THROUGH
THE BUDGET. LAST YEAR- WE'RE
GONNA BE STANDING UP THIS NEW
EXTREME HEAT GRANT PROGRAMS.
WITH AN INVESTMENT OF A HUNDRED
MILLION THAT CAME THROUGH LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS TO TARGET EXACTLY THOSE
ADDITIONAL PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDS THAT ARE
NEEDED. IN ADDITION TO IN A
WORKING IN CONCERT WITH THE
OTHER INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON IT FOUND ON THE
GROUND A POEM EDUCATION THROUGH
OTHER. AVENUES OF THE BUDGET FOR
IT THANK YOU- OVERALL OF. A NEW
SHE NO AND I NOTE ALL THAT THE-
THE ADMINISTRATION'S NOT
PROPOSING TO INCREASE THE FUNDS
FOR THE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE ND
HE PROGRAM- IT'LL BE A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM FOR
COMMUNITIES WERE REPEATEDLY
IMPACTED BY EXTREME HEAT. TO
SUBMIT PROPOSALS TO LOWER URBAN
HEAT ISLANDS AND MITIGATE AND
ACTUALLY PREVENT PICKS- EXTREME
HEAT. SO SHE NOTES AND I THINK-
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T TAKE
THERE SHOULD BE MORE FUNDING
ALLOCATED TO THAT. YEAH THANK
YOU ALSO FOR THAT QUESTION- AS
I'VE NOTED A COUPLE TIMES WE ARE
VERY EXCITED TO LAUNCH THAT
PROGRAM WE THINK IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND GONNA
HELP ADDRESS MANY YOU KNOW GAPS
THAT ARE OUT THERE IN TERMS OF
FUNDING- BUT BEFORE REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. WE WANTED TO
FOCUS ON STANDING UP THE PROGRAM
AND ALSO WORKING THROUGH A
PUBLIC GUIDELINE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS TO REALLY HELP US
IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES WHERE
THIS FUNDING CAN ADDRESS REALLY
STRATEGIC GAPS IN. THE LOCAL
PLANNING ADDRESSING URBAN HEAT
ISLAND AND SOME OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES. AND
REALLY BEING ABLE TO TARGET
THOSE TO NEAR TERM HIGH IMPACT
INVESTMENTS AND THEN LEARNING
FROM THAT AND ONCE WE HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. I CAN KIND OF THE
SCOPE OF. FUNDING THAT MAY BE
NEEDED LONG TERM AND ALSO WHERE
BEST TO TARGET THOSE FINE SO
YOU'RE REALLY WANTING TO GET
THIS PROGRAM UP AND RUNNING
LEARN FROM THAT AND THEN BE ABLE
TO HAVE AN INFORMED CONVERSATION
AROUND ADDITIONAL FUNDING. IN
THE NATURE OF. WITH THAT OF THE
QUESTION THAT- THE CHAIR BROUGHT
UP EARLIER ABOUT PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING BEING USED TO A
COULD BE A POTENTIAL WAY TO
EXPAND IF UP PROPERLY IT FUNDING
WAS USED FOR THE SCHOOL READING
PROGRAM- I JUST HAVE ONE FINAL
QUESTION AND THAT IS- TO POINT
OUT THAT- IF WE HAVE THIS
CONSTANT TENSION AND I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND AND
LEVERAGE USING RUTLAND TIME
FINDINGS FOR WHAT. FEELS LIKE
ONGOING IN. SPEND A CHURCH AND
TO- A YOU NEXT- IN FORCED HAS-
CAL OSHA PAGE TWENTY TWO- WE
HAVE- POSITION UNFORTUNATE
POSITIONS HERE. IT'S KIND OF
HARD TO IMAGINE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO STOP ENFORCING- ON EXTREME
HEAT TO THE ISSUE SAID AND- BUT
IT'S COMING OUT OF ONE TIME
FUNDING SO- THE TO THE EXTENT
THAT- WERE ALL AWARE OF THAT AND
WE CAN TRY TO MINIMIZE THAT-
DOES ANYBODY HAVE RESPONSE IN
TERMS OF. HOW WOULD YOU PLAN ON
YOU KNOW MOVING FORWARD WITH
THAT- CENTER USING ONE TIME
MONEY FOR ENFORCEMENT POSITIONS
. I CAN'T SPEAK TO THOSE
ACTIVITIES SPECIFICALLY BUT- AS
I NOTED PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED
FUNDING DOES HAVE EXTENDED
INCUMBENTS AVAILABILITY SO WE DO
SEE IT SUPPORTING SEVERAL YEARS
OF THESE ACTIVITIES. BUT GIVEN
THAT THE ACTION PLAN IS NEWLY
RELEASED WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S
PRUDENT TO UTILIZE THIS ONE TIME
FUNDING TO JUMPSTART THESE
ACTIVITIES AND THEN EVALUATE
ONGOING NEEDS FOR THE FUTURE.
VERY COMMON TECHNIQUE HI THANK
YOU. THANK YOU QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
WE HAVE- THE P. ARE WITH US.
WELCOME DIRECTOR THANK YOU.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. BOB GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI MY
NAME IS SHIRLEY HENDERSON I'M
THE IRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION MORNING
MY NAME IS KAREN MORRISON AND
ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
PATTY CARE. SO I'D LIKE TO JUST
QUICKLY START WITH AN OVERVIEW
OF THE DEPARTMENT. OUR MISSION
IS TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT- BY REGULATING
PESTICIDES SALES AND USE. BY
FOSTERING REDUCED RISK PEST
MANAGEMENT. WE'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE STATE'S PESTICIDE
REGULATORY PROGRAM AND EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE STATE'S
PESTICIDE USE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS IS ESSENTIAL TO
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. ENFORCEMENT IT'S A
SHAREDRESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN
DPR AT THE STATE LEVEL AND
COUNTY AYE COMMISSIONERS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. WE PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT OF LOCAL PESTICIDE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS BY THE
COUNTY AYE COMMISSIONERS AND
THEIR STOP. OUR VISION IS TO
ACCELERATE THE SYSTEM MY
TRANSITION OF SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
STEWARDING OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT FOOD PRODUCTION AND
SUPPORTING EFFECTIVE URBAN PEST
MANAGEMENT. WE'RE ENGAGING AND
COLLABORATING WITH ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO AFFECT THIS
TRANSITION AND PROTECT HUMAN
HEALTH THE ENVIRONMENT
PARTICULARLY OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE PROPOSED
THREE BCPS THIS BUDGET CYCLE
TODAY I'M PRESENTING OUR
PROPOSAL TO STRENGTHEN
CALIFORNIANS PESTICIDE. USE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM IT ENSURES
THAT THE STATE HAS MULTIPLE
TOOLS TO ENFORCE STATEWIDE
COMPLIANCE TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. THE REQUEST IS FOR
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS. FROM THE DPR
FINES FOR THREE PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO INVESTIGATE AND
DEVELOP PESTICIDE RESIDUE AND
USE ENFORCEMENT CASES AND FOR
FUNDS TO HIRE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO REPRESENT
DPR AND SEVEN ALL CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL USE ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
. WELL THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PESTICIDE USE AND CALIFORNIA IT
COMPLIES WITH STATE LAW AND
REGULATION STRENGTHEN
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS WILL BETTER TO
TURN BAD ACTORS AND IN DOING SO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
THOSE WHO USE PESTICIDES
RESPONSIBLY. THE PROPOSAL ALIGNS
WITH OUR GOAL TO ACCELERATE THE
TRANSITION TO SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT. AND
TO BETTER ENSURE THE PESTICIDE
USE IS SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WOULD
REINSTATE DVRS ADMINISTRATIVE
PESTICIDE USE ENFORCEMENT AND
PENALTY AUTHORITY AS AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL AT THE STATE
LEVEL. IT WOULD ALSO INCREASE
THE ADMINISTRATIVE STATUTORY
ADMINISTRATIVE CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL PENALTY CAPS THAT HAVE
REMAINED UNCHANGED FOR DECADES
AND BETTER ALIGN WITH USEPA AND
CALLIE PA BOARD AND DEPARTMENT
FIND LEVELS. AND FINALLY IT
WOULD STRENGTHEN DPR S.
PESTICIDE RESIDUE ADMINISTRATIVE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY. AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- LA OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK
JIMENEZ WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD MAKE SEVERAL
CHANGES THAT PESTICIDE
ENFORCEMENT IN PENALTY LEVELS
FOR CERTAIN VIOLATIONS
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
PESTICIDE USE RESIDUE SALES AND
LICENSING- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL EXPANDS ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY FOR DPR IN TWO MAJOR
WAYS. FIRST THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE DPR WITH
THE AUTHORITY TO LEVY
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES FOR
PESTICIDE USE VIOLATIONS WHICH
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY DOES NOT
HAVE. RECOMMENDED THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED ADDITIONAL-
MAJORITY BEING REQUESTED THE
ADDITIONAL FORSMAN AUTHORITY
WOULD ALLOW THE STATE TO SERVICE
THE BACKSTOP TO LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT WHEN MERITED SUCH AS
SERIOUS MULTI JURISDICTIONAL
VIOLATIONS WHILE STILL
MAINTAINING- COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AS THE PRIMARY
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
ARMENTA ALSO REESTABLISH SIMILAR
THIRTY DEPARTMENT PREVIOUSLY
HELD. SECOND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE DPR WITH
ADDITIONAL RESIDUE ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY SUCH AS ALLOWING THE
DEPARTMENT TO LEVY
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES TO
ENTITIES THAT DISTRIBUTOR MOVE
PRODUCE THAT HAVE BEEN
QUARANTINED DUE TO POTENTIAL
ISSUES WITH PASS THAT I
TESTIFIED RESIDUES. I'M
RECOMMENDED THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE ADDITIONAL THIRTY
BEING REQUESTED WE FIND THAT
THESE CHANGES COULD BETTER
ENABLE THE STATE TO PREVENT
CONTAMINATED PRODUCE FROM
REACHING CONSUMERS- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO
INCREASE AND ESTABLISH NEW
PENALTIES ACROSS VARIOUS TYPES
OF PESTICIDE VIOLATIONS. THESE
CHANGES CAN BE FOUND IN THE
TABLE ON YOUR AGENDA OVERALL WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
INCREASE PESTICIDE RELATED
PENALTIES AND ALLOW THE DIRECTOR
TO ADJUST PENALTIES IN FUTURE
YEARS FOR INFLATION. IN MANY
CASES PENALTIES HAVE NOT BEEN
INCREASED IN SEVERAL DECADES ON
A BUS LOST THEIR ABILITY TO
DETER VIOLATIONS OVER TIME-
INCREASES COULD INCLUDE
IMPROVING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED PENALTY LEVELS WHICH
APPEAR REASONABLE. ARE SETTING
PENALTY LEVEL SOMEWHAT HIGHER
LOWER BASED ON WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE DEEMS APPROPRIATE.
AND THEN FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING TO
SUPPORT DPR PESTICIDE USE AND
RESIDUE ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES
RECOMMENDED THE LEGISLATURE
PROVE THE FUNDING BEING
REQUESTED. I'M DELUSIONAL
FUNDING WOULD ENABLE DEPARTMENT
TO CONDUCT THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROPOSED
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT OF
PENALTY AUTHORITY AND ALLOWED TO
DEPARTMENT TO REFER SERIOUS. AND
VIOLENT ACTIONS TO TURN. FIRST
HAPPEN TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINAL. LIVE
THE AREA OF FINANCE COMMENTS
HELPING QUESTIONS THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY. MISTER BENNETT OF I
WAS IN THE OPPRESSION THAT THE
PENALTIES ARE BEING ADJUSTED FOR
INFLATION YOU'RE THE L. A. L.
COMMENTS SUGGEST THAT THEY
AREN'T BEING ADJUSTED FOR
INFLATION COULD YOU HELP ME WITH
THAT. NO THEY THEY ARE BEING AN
IMPRESSION AND- THE PENALTIES
WOULD BE IN PLACE IT WOULD BE
ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION ON GOING
AS PROPOSED. OKAY SO YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE COMMENTING
THAT THAT THAT'S A GOOD THING OR
NOT NOT THAT IT'S MISSING RIGHT
OKAY YES CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU.
AND AB I JUST WANT TO. REITERATE
PUT THAT SAY OFTENTIMES BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT WERE THE
TWO CULTURES WHERE ADJUSTING FOR
INFLATION ON ON THESE THINGS
QUICKLY FOR PENALTY- IF A
PENALTY DOESN'T GET ADJUSTED FOR
TWENTY YEARS THIS IS NOT THE
SAME PENALTIES IT WAS TWENTY
YEARS AGO ON CHRISTMAS. FIRST
BILLION SO APPRECIATE THAT I DO
HAVE ONE- OF THE- QUESTION- AND
ON THE PLUS SIDE IMPORTANT
PROGRAM. HAS THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION CONSIDERED
INCREASING FUNDING FOR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT. OPTIONS AND IN
PARTICULAR. SCHOOLS A PAST SIDE
. SHOULD USE NEAR SCHOOLS EXCEPT
HER TO BE ABLE TO HELP
AGRICULTURE COMMISSIONER SWISS
THAT ISSUE IT IS- AN EXTREMELY
SENSITIVE ISSUE IN THE STATE IS
MANNED- COULD. YOU HELP ME WITH
THAT WHAT'S YOUR POSITION ON
THAT AND ARE YOU CONSIDERING
THAT. SURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF A QUESTION ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
DOING IS TRYING TO GET A BETTER
HANDLE ON COMPLIANCE- WITH- THE
CURRENT REGULATIONS THAT APPLY
TO PESTICIDE REGULAR USE AROUND
SCHOOLS- THE CURRENT REPORTING-
IS. IT DOESN'T ALWAYS
NECESSARILY CAPTURE THE ACCURATE
LOCATION ON A PARTICULAR FIELD
GIVEN THE NATURE OF REPORTING SO
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE AYE
COMMISSIONERS TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO ALLOW GROWERS TO
BETTER AND MORE ACCURATELY
IDENTIFY WHERE THOSE
APPLICATIONS ARE HAPPENING. AND
SO ONCE WE HAVE A BETTER SENSE
OF- THE COMPLIANCE WILL EVALUATE
WHETHER WE HAVE TO WHETHER
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT RULES
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE WE'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH SCHOOLS TO. WORK
MORE CLOSELY WITH THEM TO GET A
BETTER SENSE OF WHETHER THERE
ARE VIOLATIONS OCCURRING- THAT
WE MAY NOT BE AWARE OF AND SO
ONCE WE HAVE THAT INFORMATION
WELL IT WILL TAKE ANOTHER LOOK
AT WHETHER. WE SHOULD ADOPT ANY
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT TOOLS
FROM AROUND SCHOOL IT IS
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE MOST
EXPLOSIVE TOPICS WE HAVE OUT
THERE. BUT BASED ON SOME
EXPERIENCES THAT WE'VE HAD IN.
THE VENTURA COUNTY WHO WERE ONCE
IT HAPPENS IT'S A GROUP EARLY ON
THE PUBLIC'S RADAR. SCREEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR FONG WELCOME
TO THE- IN SYSTEMS AND AGAIN. I
THANK THE CHAIR- BABY MAYBE IT'S
BECAUSE THE AT DEPARTMENT OF AT
TO BUT I'M READING AND IT SEEMS
LIKE THERE'S THAT A PING PONG
BACK AND FORTH YOU HAD IT
ALREADY EXPIRED AND THAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR THE FORTY BACK- WHY
WHY ARE YOU ASKING FOR THE
AUTHORITY BACK IS OR SOMETHING
THAT'S- THAT THE CA SEES AREN'T
DOING. WHAT WHAT IS WHAT IS THE
RATIONALE- THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION AND YOU'RE CORRECT WE
DID HAVE THE AUTHORITY AND IT
EXPIRED AND SO WE ARE- WE'RE
ASKING TO HAVE IT REINSTATED THE
REASON- THAT WE ARE REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL THIRTY IS FOR IT TO
PARTICULAR TYPES OF CASES- ONE
OF WHICH WOULD BE. CASES WHERE
VIOLATIONS ARE HAPPENING IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS- AND THE
OTHER IS IF AN AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER IS OF NOT
FULFILLING- IF HIS OR HER
DUTIES- AND SO THE I THINK THE
IMPORTANT THING TO UNDERSTAND IS
IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR STATE
OVERSIGHT ROLE OF THE PESTICIDE
REGULATORY PROGRAM. WE PROVIDE
AS AS THE L. A. O. MENTION A
BACKSTOP- IN CASES WHERE- NUMBER
ONE IF THE ACTION IS NOT BEING
TAKEN BUT NUMBER TWO IN A MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL CONTACTS WHERE
IT'S JUST FAR MORE COMPLEX- FOR
INDIVIDUAL COMMISSIONERS TO
EFFECTIVELY. ENFORCE THOSE TYPES
OF VIOLATIONS SORT IS YOUR
CONCLUSION THEN THAT
COMMISSIONERS CAN'T WORK
TOGETHER THAT OUT THAT THE STATE
HAS TO COME IN AND DO IT. NO NOT
AT ALL- IT'S JUST A MORE COMPLEX
UNDERTAKING- WHEN THERE ARE
VIOLATIONS HAPPENING IN MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS AND IN ADDITION
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE- FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAD IT RESET ACTION-
AGAINST AN AERIAL APPLICATOR
WHO- BECAUSE DRIFT INCIDENTS ON
SOCCER FIELD SCHOOLS IN MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT CROPS AND WE ENGAGED-
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AS
PART OF THAT AND- SO IN CASES
WHERE IT. WE WANT TO REFER A
CASE- FOR EXAMPLE TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE OUR
ENGAGEMENT HELPS TO COORDINATE
THE ACTIVITIES. AND SO I JUST
ITSIT PROVIDES A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE. OVERSIGHT TO
ENFORCEMENT. SALEMME DOUBLE
DEEPER HERE BECAUSE YOU'RE ST
THERE ISN'T ANY PROBLEM BUT YOU
WANT THE AUTHORITY. WHY WOULDN'T
YOU JUST INCREASED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES UNDER
THE CURRENT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
COUNTIES. I'M AS YOU SAID THAT
THERE IS NO THAT NOT THAT YOU
CAN POINT OUT ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THIS YEAR'S USE RIGHT NOW. NO I
GUESS WHAT I'M SAYING IS I THINK
IT'S MORE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
MORE EFFECTIVE IN OUR OVERSIGHT
ROLE IF WE ARE ABLE TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR TAKING ACTION
WHEN THERE ARE VIOLATIONS IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS AS
OPPOSED TO INDIVIDUAL ACTIONS.
BY INDIVIDUAL COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONERS. SO HOW SO HEY.
I'M I'M TRYING TO I'M TRYING TO
PUT THE TWO SCENARIOS A MAN
TRYING TO PUT THE TWO ARGUMENTS
THAT YOU BAY TOGETHER THERE IS
NO PROBLEM NOW. BUT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR THE AUTHORITY. AND IN
SOME OUT YOU I SAID WHY CAN'T
THE COUNTY AND AGRICULTURE
COMMISSIONS WORK TOGETHER AND
YOU SAID THEY CAN BUT YOU'D BE
BETTER. SO BUT IF THE COUNTY
COMMISSIONERS CAN ALREADY WORK
TOGETHER DO AN INVESTIGATION GO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND YOU
INCREASE THE PENALTIES ALREADY
WITHIN THE POWER WITHIN THE CA
SEES WHY NOT ALLOW THAT INSTEAD
OF CREATING A WHOLE NEW
AUTHORITY- FIT. THE QUESTION I
SHOULD STEP BACK AND SAY THAT-
WE ARE STICKING NOT AUTHORITY AT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE LEVEL. SO
THAT WHEN WE WERE FOR TODAY-
THE- CASE AT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE THAT WAS WE
UNDERTAKE THAT ACTION THAT
PARTICULAR ACTION A LICENSING
CONTEXT WHAT WE'RE SEEKING AND
THIS CASE IS FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
AND FOR PESTICIDE USE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY. SO IF AN
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSION AND
COUNTY A SUBPOPULATION AND THE
SAME- GROWER WAS COMMITTING A
VIOLATION COUNTY . THOSE
ACTIONS WOULD OCCUR
INDEPENDENTLY AND POTENTIALLY
NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE OVERALL ACTION OF. THAT
PARTICULAR ACTOR AND SO IF WE AS
DPR WERE ABLE TO. TAKE A LOOK
AND BE ABLE TO ENFORCE AGAINST
BOTH OF THOSE VIOLATIONS. WE
BELIEVE IT WOULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE- BECAUSE WE WOULD HAVE
A MORE HOLISTIC APPROACH AND BE
ABLE TO SEE. THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS AS OPPOSED
TO INDIVIDUAL VIOLATIONS
HAPPENING IN INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES
SO YOU'RE SAYING. A GOOD ADD
THIS THIS- TYPE OF AUTHORITY AND
HEARING OF A THIRTEEN. OTHER
STATE LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES OF THE L. A. O. PER
PART NOTE CPSC HAS SIMILAR.
COVER CYCLE. AUTHOR BLACK. MY
CHARACTER OF SIR VIOLATE NEED.
AGENTS TO BE ABLE TO. AND TAKEN.
ACTIONS FOLLOWING CONSULTATION
WITH THE COMMISSIONERS. OKAY BUT
YOU'RE SAYING OTHER OTHER
AGENCIES HAVE THE AUTHORITY WHEN
I TALK ABOUT AGENCIES ARE DONE
WITH THIS ONE SO WHY DID THE WHY
DID THE AUTHORITY LAPSE. C.
THIRTY LAST IN AT LEAST TWO
THOUSAND SIX- AND WAS- AND PART
OF A SERIES OF AMENDMENTS TO THE
STATUTE THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
THE OVERALL PENALTY LEVELS AND
SO AT THE TIME THE PENALTY
LEVELS WERE MIRRORING BOTH STATE
AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES AND SO I
CAN'T COME INTO THE FULL
DECISION MAKING THAT WAS MADE AT
THAT TIME BUT I BELIEVE IT WAS
TIED TO- THE DIFFERENT COUNCILS
OR INCREASED ON THE-
COMMISSIONER ADMINISTRATIVE
AUTHORITY. OKAY SO ANY ANALYSIS
IT SAID THAT AB NINE FOUR SEVEN
ALLOWED THE AUTHORITY TO SUNSET-
I GUESS I'M I'M STRUGGLING TO
UNDERSTAND. NOT THAT THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO DO ENFORCEMENT OR
NOT TO DO PENALTIES IF THAT IS
THERE A PROBLEM IN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM THAT REQUIRES NEW
AUTHORITY OR CAN THE EXISTING
PROGRAM WORK AND WE INCREASE THE
PENALTIES. BECAUSE YOU SAID THAT
YOU THE YOU THAT YOU HIGHLIGHTED
THAT IF AN ACT COMMISSIONER IS
NOT FULFILLING THEIR DUTIES BUT
YOUHAVE NO EXAMPLE ACT MR NOT
FILLING THEIR DUTIES. I THINK
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS- BE
PROACTIVE AND ANTICIPATE
SITUATIONS WHERE WE WANT THE
STATE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE. ALL OF
THE AVAILABLE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
EFFECTIVELY. ENFORCE THE STATE'S
PESTICIDE LAWS AND REGULATIONS
TO PROTECT HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND NOT WANT TO
HAVE TO UN RING A BELL THAT'S
ALREADY HAPPENED AND SO. THIS IS
NOT. THAT WOULD NOT BE AN OPTION
THAT WE WOULD TAKE LIGHTLY UNDER
ANY CIRCUMSTANCES IT WOULD ONLY
BE AN EXTREME CASE WHERE ACTION
ISN'T BEING TAKEN. AND I THINK
GOING BACK TO THE MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL ISSUE IF I MAY I
THINK- IF THERE WAS AN ACTION
THAT OF A GROUP OR FOR EXAMPLE A
VIOLATION TOOK PLACE IN COUNTY A
AND SO THAT I COMMISSIONER IS
LOOKING JUST AT THAT. VIOLATION
AND IS CONSIDERING A FINE LEVEL
BASED ON THAT SINGLE VIOLATION.
AND THEN THERE'S A SEPARATE
ACTION TAKING PLACE IN ANOTHER
COUNTY AND AGAIN NOT AYE
COMMISSIONER IS LOOKING JUST AT
THAT CASE DOT VIOLATION. WE AT
THE STATE LEVEL WOULD STEP BACK
AND SAY OKAY THIS ACTOR IS.
VIOLATING IN MULTIPLE COUNTIES
AND SO WE WILL LOOK BELIEVE THAT
THAT DESERVES A HIGHER LEVEL OF
FINE AND PENALTY. GIVEN THE
MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE EACH INDIVIDUAL AYE
COMMISSIONER WOULD ONLY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EXAMINE AND CONSIDER.
THE VIOLATION AND HIS OR HER
COUNTY IN ASSESSING FINE BUT
UNDER THAT OKAY SO LET'S LET'S
GO FORWARD WITH THAT EXAMPLE.
THEN WHY NOT JUST INCREASE. ****
WITHIN EACH. SO IF THERE'S
MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS I SAY YOU
YOU INCREASE THE PENALTIES SO
THAT THAT PERSON PAYS MULTIPLE
PENALTIES IN BOTH JURISDICTIONS. I COMMISSIONER AND COUNTY A IS
GOING TO BE CONSIDERING THE
VIOLATION IN HIS OR HER COUNTY.
AND SIMILARLY THE AG
COMMISSIONER AND COUNTY B. IS
GOING TO BE CONSIDERING A
VIOLATION AS A AND HIS OR HER
COUNTY. AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
BE CONSIDERING THE MULTITUDE OF
VIOLATIONS THAT THAT ACTOR HAS
COMMITTED WE AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND OVERSEEING THE- ENFORCEMENT
AT A STATEWIDE LEVEL AND LOOKING
AT THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
VIOLATIONS. WOULD BE ABLE TO AN
APPROPRIATELY CONSIDER THOSE
MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS AND COMING
UP WITH A FINE LEVEL. OKAY I
GUESS- I SEE. WHAT WOULD BE THE
DIFFERENCE THEN BETWEEN MIGHT
MIGHT Y. SCENARIO YOUR SCENARIO
HERE YOU'RE JUST ASKING TO
AGGREGATE AND- AND SOMEHOW
IMPOSE A FINE WHERE I'M SAYING
THE INCREASE THE FINES ON AND AT
AT AT AT EACH LEVEL AND SO EACH
VIOLATION HAS A HIGHER FINE UP
FROM. I THINK WHAT I'M TRYING TO
SAY IS OUR ROLE IS MORE THAN AN
AGGREGATOR OUR ROLE IS LOOKING
AT A TOTAL PICTURE BECAUSE IT
AND I COMMISSIONER WILL LOOK AT
A VIOLATION IN HIS OR HER COUNTY
AND REALLY CONSIDERED JUST
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN HIS OR HER
COUNTY AS OPPOSED TO OUR ROLE
WHICH WOULD BE LOOKING AT THAT
THE OVERALL STATEWIDE ACTIVITIES
AND VIOLATIONS OF THAT
PARTICULAR AFTER. SO IT'S
GREATER THAN THE SUM OF ITS JUST
A VIA A PENALTY OF A THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ONE COUNTY IN THE
THOUSAND DOLLAR FILE. PENALTY IN
ANOTHER AND WE'RE SAYING THIS
ACTOR IS THIS REGARDING THE LAW
IS COMMITTING MULTIPLE
VIOLATIONS WE THINK THAT'S-
WORTH THE PENALTY OF FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO I WE HAVE A
IN A BROADER STATEWIDE WE HAVE A
BROADER STATEWIDE OVERSIGHT ROLE
THAN ANY INDIVIDUAL I
COMMISSIONER ASSURANCE HAS ARE
COUNTING. I WILL I GOT ANOTHER
QUESTION I JUST I DON'T BELIEVE
AT THAT POINT I JUST I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF THE
RATIONALE WHEN A ACT IN AN WHEN
SOMEONE IS FIND OR WHEN A FARMER
OR A- OR AG OPERATORS. OR PASSES
I JUST- AGGREGATORS FIDE WHERE
DOES THE MONEY GO. JUNE SHORT
THOSE THOSE- FINDS DID PRIMARILY
GO BACK TO THE COUNTIES- FORWARD
PESTICIDE USE ENFORCEMENT. CIVIL
PENALTIES SEVERAL ADMINISTRATIVE
CIVIL PENALTIES SO IN IN IN THIS
NEW PROPOSAL DOES THAT STILL.
OPERATE THE SAME WAY. FOR THE
PENALTIES THAT OUR LOVE YOU GOT
THE COUNTY LEVEL YES- FOR THOSE
THAT ARE LIVING AT THE STATE
LEVEL THERE IS SOME PROVISIONS
TO. CONSIDER THOSE HEALTH IS
BOTH GOING BACK TO THE COUNTY AS
WELL AS TO THE STATE. AND DO YOU
HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT THE
BREAKDOWN IS HOW MUCH GOES TO
THE COUNTY HOW MUCH OF THE
STATE. NOT AT THIS TIME BUT I
WILL NOTE THAT THE BREAKDOWN IS-
WERE PRIMARILY LOOKING AT THE
AND FINDS A WAY TO- ADDRESS
CONCERNS OF BEHAVIOR NOT AS A
SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. OKAY IF YOU COULD
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO ME I
WOULD VERY MUCH APPRECIATE- TO
SEE WHERE THE- FINES WOULD GO-
AND HOW MUCH WE GO TO THE STATE
AND. HOW MUCH WOULD GO TO THE
COUNTY THANK YOU SO MUCH TERRY.
CERTAINLY MISTER BENNETT. I WAS
JUST GOING TO REACH TO MY
COLLEAGUES SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
AND THAT IS THAT- WHILE THERE
MAY NOT BE EVIDENCE OF SPECIFIC
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS NOT
AND FORCING GOT IT FIXED- I FEEL
MY EXPERIENCE OVER TWENTY YEARS
THE CASHIER OF AS WE COULD FIND
THAT BOOK CROSSES STATE IN
SIMILAR SITUATIONS AND- AND
CERTAINLY I THINK WE'VE HEARD TO
THEM IDENTIFIED REPEATEDLY THAT.
THE ABILITY TO LOOK AT THE
AGGREGATES BEHAVIOR ACROSS
COUNTY SIS THAT ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE GREAT ADVANTAGES OF THIS
PROGRAM SO I THINK THEY'RE TWO
BIG ADVANTAGES ONE AND OVERSIGHT
FOR AG COMMISSIONERS THAT MAY
NOT BE ENFORCING- APPROPRIATELY
AND THE OTHER IS THE ABILITY TO
AGGREGATE AGGREGATE BECAUSE FOR
A BAD ACTOR THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDES ULTIMATELY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING SURE
THAT. WE DON'T GET THESE
PESTICIDE TO ABUSE SPRAYING. SIX
CETERA THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND-
I THIS IS A- PONTUS PROPOSAL
IT'S NOT A HECK OF A LOT OF
MONEY IN THE REQUEST AND IT'S
GOING TO GO A LONG WAY TO.
HELPING US ADDRESS SO BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT OUR ONGOING ISSUES-
WITH A PESTICIDE REGULAR
REGULATION VIOLATIONS I THINK-
IT SAYS SOMETHING THAT- HOPE. TO
BE ABLE TO SUBORDINATE. IN THE
IN IN IN THE BUDGET BUT WE ARE
GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO- ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
I MISSED MY OPPORTUNITY.
ACCEPTABLE. WE HAVE A STEP A
CORE WE'RE NOT TAKE ANY VOTE SO
THE QUORUM ISN'T APPS IS BUT-
AND MAY HAVE MISSED MY OP. ISSUE
FOUR IS ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
PACKAGE ACCELERATION AND- WE
HAVE WITH US I BELIEVE THAT
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER CRAIG
SICKELS. THAT'S YEAH BUT WELL
AYE FINANCE WILL BE MAKING THE
OPENING COMMENTS TODAY MR OKAY
CHANGE OF PACE PLEASE SO GOOD
MORNING I CHAIRED WOMEN MEMBERS
CHRISTIAN CULTURE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
LIKE TO START BY HIGHLIGHTING
THAT THE PARTICULAR POLLS BUT
PROPOSAL BEING DISCUSSED IS JUST
A COMPONENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BROADER RELIEF
PACKAGE- THAT WAS RELEASED IN
MARCH- SPECIFICALLY THE RELIEF
PACKAGE INCLUDES A RELIEF
REFINED INCENTIVE GRANTS TO
TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES TO
MAKE WRITING PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION FREE FOR THREE
MONTHS. A PAUSE ON THE GENERAL
FUND PORTION OF THE SALES TAX
RATE AND DIESEL AND A FEW OTHER
ITEMS BUT SPECIFICALLY THIS
PARTICULAR ACCELERATION OF
CERTAIN PROPOSED ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PROGRAMS IS THE ITEM
BEFORE YOU TODAY. AND OTHER
COMPONENTS OF THE PACKAGE
PROPOSED BY THIS PROPONENT THE
PACKAGE- PROPOSED EXCEL OVER
ACCELERATE ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TEN BILLION THE
PROPOSAL TO MOVE CAN. IN
TRANSPORTATION UP. THERE REDUCE
OUR OVERALL. ON GAS AND FOSSIL
FUELS SPECIFICALLY THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES
ACCELERATING SIX HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THAT FUELING. INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION TO SUPPORT LOW INCOME
CONSUMER PURCHASES INCLUDING THE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL AND FINANCING
ASSISTANCE. FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN MILLION FOR ZERO
EMISSION MOBILITY PROGRAMS AND
THREE HUNDRED MILLION PRESERVE
EQUITABLE AT HOME CHARGING.%
EXHILARATING THIS FUNDING INTO
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TO HELP THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO INITIATE THE
PROCESS SEES TO IMPLEMENT THIS
FUNDING. RATHER THAN WAITING ON
UNCERTAIN FISCAL FUTURE FUNDING
ISSUES IT HELPS CREATE ABOUT
GREATER MARKET CERTAINTY AND
ENABLES CONSUMERS TO PLAN THEIR
VEHICLE PURCHASES WITH
CONFIDENCE. THAT THEY WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO VEHICLE REBATES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THESE EARLY PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS PROVIDE A CLEAR
SIGNAL TO THE PRIVATE MARKET TO
MAKE INVESTMENTS AND ACCELERATE
THEIR ACTIVITIES. I WILL HAND IT
OFF NOW TO MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENTS- PERSON BE COMMENTS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION ADDRESSING THE
COMMITTEES QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
I THINK I'M NEXT IN LINE AS A
CHAPLAIN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANKS FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY. I'M CRAIG SIEGEL
THAT COULD BE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FROM MOBILE SOURCES AND
INCENTIVES A PROVIDE CARDS
TESTIMONY ON THIS PART OF THE
PACKAGE. I'LL FOCUS ON THE
PROGRAMS INVOLVED RATHER THAN
THE BUDGET DECISIONS ON THAT
DIFFERENT FINANCE HAS PUT
FORWARD. AND SUPPORT. NONE THE
BOOK FROM HOME OF THIS. THAT ARE
BEING ACCELERATED. WERE PROVIDED
TOLD OF FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PURCHASE INCENTIVES FOR
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS THE
CURRENT YEAR. THIS INCLUDES AT
LEAST TWENTY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL OUR LOW INCOME AND
SUPPORT PROGRAM FOR NEW VEHICLE
PURCHASES ARE USED. STATEWIDE
PLUS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE DISTRICT RUN CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAMS. AT LEAST A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR STATEWIDE
FINANCING ASSISTANCE FOR LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS. AT LEAST
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
NEW ELECTRIC BIKE INCENTIVE
INCENTIVES PROJECT WHICH WE ARE
WATCHING THIS YEAR. EXPANDING
THESE PROGRAMS MORE RAPIDLY WILL
PROVIDE ECONOMIC BENEFITS TO LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WILL
SUPPORTING THIS HAVE TRANSITION
. IN ADDITION- FOUR HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS A
PROPOSED FOR CELEBRATION FOR
ZERO EMISSION MOBILITY
CATEGORIES. THIS FUNDING SUPPORT
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY BASED
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECTS
INCREASE ACCESS TO ZERO EMISSION
MOBILITY IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES AT LEAST A HUNDRED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CLEAN
MOBILITY OPTIONS PROJECT. AND
TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND
EXISTING CARD CARSHARE PILOTS.
HOUSE INCLUDES AT LEAST A
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CLEAN MOBILITY
IN SCHOOLS PROJECTS. THE
COMMITTEE HAD SOME SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS FOR CARP ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL LET ME JUST RUN THROUGH
THOSE NOW. THE FIRST WAS WIDE
ONLY FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
DEDICATED THEIR DISTRICTS WITH
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAMS. AND
IT WHAT ONE EPISODES IS THAT THE
DOWN PAYMENT TO THE DISTRICT
PROGRAMS ADICIONAL SEVENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IS ALSO PROPOSED
IN THE BUDGET FROM GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND. FOR EQUITY
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS. NONE OF
THE PREPARATION HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED- THE PROGRAMS YET. BUT
A LARGE PORTION OF THE GIRAFFE
ALLOCATION HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN
ALLOCATED TO THIS DISTRICT RUN
PROGRAMS IT'S LIKELY THIS
FUNDING WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THEM. SO THAT FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE ALLOCATIONS
FIVE THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION IN
TWENTY ONE TO TWO WHICH EXCEEDS
THE STORK MAXIMUM OF THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DISTRICT'S. SECOND QUESTION IS
ABOUT APPROVED SUBSCRIPTION OF
CARS FOR ALL. I CAN TELL YOU
THAT THE PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
OVER SUBSCRIBED IN SAN JOAQUIN
SOUTH COASTIN THE AREA-
DISTRICTS THERE'S REALLY STRONG
DEMAND. FINALLY YOU ASKED ABOUT
THE STATUS OF THE E. BIKE
PROGRAM. SELECTRIC BICYCLE
INCENTIVES PROJECT- ONE OF MY
PERSONAL FAVORITES WAS ENACTED
BY KARBI APPROVAL OF OUR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INCENTIVES.
FUNDING PLAN AND EMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SIX HUNDRED. AND HIS
FACE HAVING TO PAY. ADMIN IN
PLACE IN MIDDLE EAST TWENTY TWO.
AT THE SOLICITOR. CALL IN MAY.
AND THE WINNER OF THE
SOLICITATION TO ADMINISTER IT
WILL BE ANNOUNCED IN JUNE. THANK
YOU HAPPY ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS INAPPROPRIATE WILL
TURN OVER TO MY CC COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS HANNIBAL AND I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FIELD AND
TRANSPORTATION ABATEMENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
PUT IN A BID TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION I'M VERY MUCH A
VEHICLE THAT PERFECT- THE LACK
OF INFRASTRUCTURE CONTINUE TO BE
A LEADING BARRIER TO THE
ADOPTION. WE'RE FULLY COMMITTED
TO OVERCOMING THAT BARRIER
THROUGH LONG TERM PLANNING AND
PRIVATELY TO DEPLOY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ENSURE WE NEED
TO TACKLE. WE MUST APPOINT
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW FOR THE
DRIVERS HAVE A PLACE TO FEEL THE
VEHICLE. EVEN AFTER PROJECT HAVE
BEEN AWARDED FUNDING IT TAKES
TIME TO CONDUCT SITE DESIGN
CONSTRUCTION AND- AND
ORGANIZATION. OF THE CARTON
FICTION. AFTER THE BATSMAN WHAT
STARK AND A LOT OF MAKING ABOUT
IN LUBBOCK PRIVATE ALL. ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION LOCKED. WE
LOOK AT IT UP TO DATE BUCKETS
THREE HUNDRED NO TOWARD. VEHICLE
AFTER TRUCKER SPOKE A LOT CREEK
ANTI. IN TWO HUNDRED ML TOWARD
MEDIUM TO HEAVY DUTY UNDER.
AGAIN BOTH A LOT AND HIGH IN
THERE TO. BUILD FUND HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED TO PRIVATE. WILL BE
USED FOR. ON ONE THING THAT
BEARD THIS YEAR IT INCLUDES-
THAT WE HAVE. BETTER OVER
SUBSCRIBING OUT OF TO THOSE. IN
VEHICLE SUCH A- HI MILES VEHICLE
THANK. RURAL KING. AND
MULTIMEDIA DWELLING. WHO ALL
FINISHED THERE FOR TAKING THE
STAND UP TO NEW BLOCK GRANTS. SO
THEY ADDITIONAL FUNDING. ALL THE
ALL IT'LL HELP WITH PROVIDE
REALLY MARKET NO ALSO LOT OF TWO
MORE ROAD. PLAN CREATE CERTAINTY
THE THIRD FUNDING HOW PLAN BUT
THE CASE THAT ADDRESS GOT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE QUESTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THAT
CONCLUDES SARAH YOUR
PRESENTATION IS ALEJO HAVE
COMMENTS YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS ROSS BROWN WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SO WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS PROPOSAL
TO ACCELERATE THE FUNDING-
BECAUSE IN OUR VIEW THE BENEFITS
OF DOING SO ARE UNCLEAR AND-
THAT COULD HAVE ADVERSE EFFECTS
ON FUTURE BUDGET FLEXIBILITY NO
I'M GOING TO KIND OF RUN THROUGH
ALL OF THOSE PIECES REAL
QUICKLY. THE FIRST ON THE
BENEFIT SIDE WE THINK THAT THE
BENEFITS OF THE ACCELERATOR ON
CLEARER- JUST TO KIND OF
REITERATE I THINK SOMETHING YOU
ALREADY HEARD AND AS I'M SURE
YOU REMEMBER THE GOVERNOR AS
PART OF THIS YEAR JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSED A TEN BILLION DOLLARS
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE FUNDING
PACKAGE WHICH INCLUDED FUNDING
THAT WAS AGREED UPON LAST YEAR
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT WAS PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET.
IN JANUARY AND THAT WOULD A BID
BY. I LEVELS OF FUNDING FOR LOT
OF THESE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE.
AND THE FUNNY WOULD BE SPREAD
OUT OVER A MULTI YEAR A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD REALLY- THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ACCELERATE A
PORTION OF THAT FUNDING ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION- INTO THE
CURRENT YEAR- WE THINK THAT- IF
ACCELERATED IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER
THERE IS. SUFFICIENT DEMAND FOR
AND OF ALL THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. IN THE NEAR TERM AND OR
ADMINISTRATIVE CAPACITY TO
IMPLEMENT. THE PROJECTS MORE
QUICKLY THAN WHAT WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE OCCURRED UNDER KIND OF
A MULTI YEAR FUNDING APPROACH.
AND SO FAR THE ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T PROVIDED ANY SPECIFIC
ESTIMATES OF HOW THE PROPOSAL
WOULD ACTUALLY SORT OF SPEED UP
THE DEPLOYMENT OF. OF PROJECTS
WITH R. P. TRUCKING STATIONS OR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT
. SO ON THE SO THAT'S KIND OF ON
THE BENEFIT SIDE ON IN TERMS OF
KIND OF SOME OF THE POTENTIAL
ADVERSE EFFECTS WE THINK THAT
THE PROPOSAL REDUCES SOME OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S FLEXIBILITY TO
ADJUST. FUTURE BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS IN RESPONSE TO
UNEXPECTED BUDGETARY AND POLICY
CHANGES. SO FOR EXAMPLE IF
GENERAL FUND REVENUES DECREASED
DUE TO AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. IN
THE COMING YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD NO LONGER HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO RESPOND BY.
ADJUSTING SOME OF THESE- THAT
SPENDING. LEVELS IN FUTURE
BUDGETS- ALSO IF THERE'S AN
INCREASE IN SAID FUNDING FROM
OTHER SOURCES FOR EXAMPLE
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR. SOME OF THE
SIMILAR THAT ACTIVITIES THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE. A SEAT
AT ITS ABILITY TO ADJUST IT'S A
- PRIORITIES AND RESPONSES. HIS
SECONDLY YOU WE THINK THE
PROPOSAL REDUCE LEGISLATORS
ABILITY TO EXERCISE ITS
OVERSIGHT ROLE SO FOR EXAMPLE.
UNDER THE ORIGINAL MULTI YEAR
APPROACH THAT WAS PROPOSED. IF
FUTURE OVERSIGHT EFFORTS
DETERMINED THAT DEPARTMENTS
AREN'T IMPLEMENTING PROGRAMS
AFFECTED WITH THE LEGISLATURE
COULD WITHHOLD FUNDING UNTIL THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN SHOW THAT IT
HAS MADE IMPROVEMENTS- HOWEVER
UNDER THIS KIND OF ACCELERATION
PROPOSAL THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
FIND IT MORE DIFFICULT TO EMPLOY
THOSE. THOSE OVERSIGHT TOOLS IN
THE FUTURE. FURTHERMORE SOME OF
THE PUBLIC CONTRACTING
EXEMPTIONS PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD REDUCE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THIRD PARTY
OVERSIGHT. FROM DDS- THAT ARE
MEANT TO ENSURE THE STATE FUNDS
ARE. ARE BEING SPENT
RESPONSIBLY. SO JUST TO WRAP UP
GIVEN SOME OF THE UNCLEAR
BENEFITS AND SOME OF THE ADVERSE
EFFECTS ON A BUDGET FLEXIBILITY
IN OVERSIGHT WERE. I RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REJECTED SPUR.
THANK YOU- YOUR TAKE A STAB AT-
RESPOND AS SOME OF THOSE-
CRITICS SIDE ABSOLUTELY I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES AT
THE DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE CONCERNS. I WILL NOT
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET
PRIORITIES BUT I CAN'T SAY THESE
PROGRAMS A VERY SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT SO WHEN IT COMES TO YOU
CAN THIS FUNDS TO BE SPENT. THAT
I CAN ATTEST TO I'M IN BOTH THE
CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM AND THE
ABILITY OPTIONS PROGRAMS WE'VE
REGULARLY SEEN DEMANDS WELL
EXCEEDING SUPPLY- WHICH CAUSES
THE SERVICE START STOP. AFFECT
IN THE PROGRAM. IT ALSO MAKES IT
HARDER TO PLAN FOR LONG TERM
PERMANENT PLANTATION ONE EXAMPLE
OF THIS IS THE FINANCING
PROGRAM. WHERE WE CONSISTENTLY
SEE THAT OPEN AND CLOSE AND NOW
THE VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF
ALLOCATION I THINK FIFTEEN
MILLION FOR IT. SO PROVIDING
SOME OF THESE AND SOME OF THESE
AREAS WHETHER IT'S IN THE
MOBILITY PROGRAM THROUGH LASSEN
MISS PAL THESE PLAN AND OF THE
FULL SCOPE OF PLANNING. WE'RE
CONSISTENTLY SEE MANY MORE
APPLICATIONS THAT WE CAN FIND.
WHEN THE FINANCING YOUR CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL PROGRAMS WE ALSO
TEND TO SEE A SIMILAR EFFECT. SO
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS WE SEE
SHOULD THE SOME PROPOSAL
FORWARD. WITH AN ABILITY MORE
LONG TERM PLANNING I PROVIDE
MORE CERTAINTY BOTH TO
MANUFACTURE SENTIMENTS POLITIES
- I'M VALUE FOR. IN THE- WE DO
YOU LOOK AT DO YOU TO THE- ISSUE
OF REDUCING LEGISLATIVE ATTEMPTS
RE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT UP FOR
TO MY FINANCE COLLEAGUES FOR
THAT YEAH ABSOLUTELY SO- THE IN
SHINS AT STANDARDIZED AND WE'RE
MORE THAN WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAINTAIN THAT
THEIR SON OVERSIGHT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAINTAINS OUR WHILE
THESE DOLLARS ARE BEING ROLLED
OUT AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON THAT. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MISTER
BENNETT. A AND WALDRON. YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON THE- SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
GENERAL FUND FOR THE V. CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE- I WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE OUT OF EVERYTHING I.
CERTAINLY RESPECT THE CONCERNS
OF LA- TO THE EXTENT THAT WEEK
XCELERATED DOES- I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE- PUT A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF BONUS POINTS FOR
PEOPLE THAT HAVE STORAGE
CAPACITY AS PART OF THOSE- WITH
THE GRID OF PROBLEMS THAT ARE
PROTECTED BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE- ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THAT IS TO
INCREASE STORAGE AND HAVE PEOPLE
USING THE GRID- DURING THE OFF
HOURS AND THEN USING THEIR
STORAGE. TO HELP US- DURING
THOSE TIME PERIODS AND STUFF SO
I WOULD HOPE THAT THERE WOULD BE
A SIGNIFICANT ENHANCEMENT OF
PROJECTS THAT HAVE THAT OR BEEN
PRIORITIZATION OF PROJECTS THAT
HAVE THAT. TWO AREAS THAT I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT FROM AN
OVERSIGHT STANDPOINT THAT I
THINK COULD TO A ROAD PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN GOVERNMENT AND
WE'VE HAD UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY
HITS LIKE THAT WITH STUFF. SOME
OF THE OTHER CRISIS THAT WE'VE
HAD BUT- THE POTENTIAL FOR ABUSE
WITH- THE CLEAN CARS PROGRAM-
ANYTIME THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
FUNDS- FOR UP TO A PUSH. A
SPECIFIC POPULATION I'M NOT
SAYING DON'T DO IT I'M SAYING
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE GOOD OVERSIGHT HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
ABUSING THOSE PROGRAMS
MANIPULATING THE- OF THE DATA
CENTER TO GET THE GRANTS. AND
THEN THE GOING TO A SOLE SOURCE
CONTRACTING- THE EXPLORATION OF
THAT- LANGUAGE OF THAT- GENERAL
SERVICES SHE IS NOT TO REVIEWING
AS WERE TRYING. THINGS SO. AND
SO THE TEMPERATURE TO GET
INCREASE FLEX- PUTS US AT AT
RISK TERMS SOURCE OF MONEY TO
GET TO RACIAL SINGS HERE TODAY-
HOPE THAT IF WE DO GO THOSE DOES
DIRECTION SO WE PUT A
SIGNIFICANT ENERGY INTO TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE MAINTAIN
THE PUBLIC'S TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE- WITH THOSE PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR TRUMP. I
THINK IT WAS CHAIR I WANTED TO-
GET INTEL A LITTLE MORE DETAIL
EAST YOU SAID THAT THE
ATTENDANCE IS TO THE- THE CC.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
NUMBERS YOU CAN YOU CAN
DEMONSTRATION DOCUMENT THE
DEMAND LIKE YOU SAID THEY'RE
OVERSUBSCRIBED OVERSUBSCRIBED BY
HOW MUCH. THE PROGRAM IS. BUT
THOSE ARE NOT THE I'M SORRY I
WOULD MAYBE DO YOU WHICH ARE TO
DEMONSTRATION. I BELIEVE YOU'RE
A REFERENCING THE COMMENT CARB
BECAUSE ABOUT THE OVER
SUBSCRIPTION IN THE CERTAIN
AREAS IS THAT YEAH I APOLOGIZE I
I'M I'M READING THAT AND- ASKING
THAT THE L. A. ELSE IS THAT
EXHILARATING THE FUNDING-
WOULDN'T REALLY CHANGING THE
TIME AS THE KEY PROGRAMS AND-
AND I THINK THE CHAIR ASKED- HOW
TO RESPOND AND I THINK I. THE
SAID- THE PROJECT AT THE WRONG
AGENCY- THAT THAT ITS OVER
SUBSCRIBED BUT BY HOW MUCH I GET
THEIR NUMBERS THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING TO BUY A FEW EXAMPLES.
IN MOBILITY PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
THE- THE COMMUNITY BUILDING
PROGRAMS PROPOSED FOR PATIENTS.
AS THOSE WINDOWS THAT OPEN FOR
THE LAST FEW YEARS HE RECEIVED
ABOUT TWENTY THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN PROPOSALS WE ARE ABLE
TO FIND ABOUT A HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OF THIS.
FOR THE STATE WITH FINANCING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND WE EXPECT
ON THE ORDER FIFTY FIVE NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS OF ANNUAL
DEMAND. THAT PROGRAM START UP
HAS BEEN SLOWED BY THE PANDEMIC
I THINK THAT' PROBABLY
REPRESENTATIVE CONSIDERING
THAT'S THE ONLY A WAY TO
FINANCING OPTION. BROOKLYN CARS
FOR ALL AND WE SEE SIGNIFICANT
OVER SUBSCRIPTION. IN MANY OF
THE- THE DISTRICTS THE COURT
ADMINISTER THEM. FOR INSTANCE WE
BELIEVE THE SANDWICH ERDAS IS
DOWN ABOUT FIFTY MILLION. AND
THERE AND THE OTHERS ARE EITHER
WRITING RIGHT WHERE THEY ARE
WITH MANY MORE APPLICATIONS
COMING IN. OR SLIGHTLY DOWN. I'M
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT-
OVERALL. SPEND RATES YOU KNOW WE
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE THE LAST
YEAR'S ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
ENCUMBERED. HOW MUCH IS ALREADY
BEING SPENT IN EXPECT GREATER
DEMAND. IN ALL THESE PROGRAMS
GOING FORWARD AS WE SEE THIS
RELEASED SHARP PIVOT TOWARD
ELECTRIFICATION- MEANING THAT.
AS THE STATE MOVES INTO THAT
AREA. WITH RIGOR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT'S POINTS WITH
CONSIDERABLE AUDIT AND COMPARE
EDUCATION. WE ARE AWARE THAT
THERE ARE LARGE NUMBER OF MIDDLE
CLASS AND LOW INCOME SOUTH
KOREANS WHO NEED THESE TOOLS.
SOME OF THESE AREAS WE DO SEE
STRONG DEMAND. EXACTLY HOW THAT
THE BAND PLAYED OUT OF COURSE IS
SUBJECT TO WHERE THE MARKET
GOES. SO IS SO ARE YOU SAYING
THAT LA WAS WRONG. NO I AM NOT
SPEAKING VALUES PARTICULAR
CRITIQUES I AM SAYING THAT THE
STRONG DEMAND FOR THESE PROGRAMS
. OKAY WELL I MEAN WE'RE I'M
TRYING I GUESS MAYBE TO THE L.
A. I'M TRYING TO WAY. TO MEET
WITH FROM YOUR ANALYSIS EVEN A
KID THAT- THAT THERE REALLY IS
NO ESTIMATES AT THE MOMENT OF
HOW THE EXHILARATED FUNDING
WOULD CHANGE THE TIME LINES FOR
KEY PROGRAM OUTCOMES. I MADE
WHAT WHAT WHAT DETAILS WHAT
NUMBERS ARE YOU UTILIZING A YOUR
NUMBERS ALIGNING. YEAH AND SO I
THINK OUR COMMENTS WERE. ALONG
THE LINES OF THAT IT WAS UNCLEAR
AT THE TIME THAT WE DID OUR
ANALYSIS AND- WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS THAT WERE JUST PRESENTED
RIGHT HERE IN THE HEARING AND SO
I THINK HAVING THAT INFORMATION.
COULD HELP SORT OF CLARIFY AND
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL CONTEXT
AROUND WHAT THOSE BENEFITS.
MIGHT BE AMENABLE NOTES- AGAIN
SORT OF THE A FUNDING FROM PRIOR
YEARS IS NOT THE SAME AS WHAT
WOULD HAVE KIND OF BEEN PROPOSED
GOING FORWARD GIVEN SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION. AROUND OF THIS OUT
BUDGET SO I THINK. SENSE OF. YOU
KNOW HOW DEMAND COMPARED TO WHAT
FUNDING WOULD GO KIND OF UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS KIND
OF IMPORTANT- PIECE OF THAT
DISCUSSION I THINK HAVING THAT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AROUND
KIND OF HOW THOSE LOCKED UP AND
WHAT. EXACTLY WOULD BE
ACCELERATED AS A RESULT OF THIS
PROPOSAL COULD. HELP INFORM THAT
DECISION WHICH WOULD THEN I
THINK MAYBE- AS YOU'RE GETTING
TO KIND OF HELP INFORM HOW TO
BALANCE. YOU KNOW WHAT HOW HOW
MUCH MORE QUICKLY SO PLEASE
PROJECT WOULD BE EMPTY. THE
OTHER. ACCOUNT AND ARE NOT. I
WOULD TO THAT DAY NOW THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND OF COURSE- THAT'S
WHY HOLD THESE ITEMS OPENNESS
THAT WE CAN RECEIVE THAT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND-
EVALUATE TO. MORE CAREFULLY-
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE- DIRECTION
AS- FOR OUR FOR MY PART I WOULD
SAY. THE ACCELERATION OF THESE
FUNDS IS GOING TO BE VERY
HELPFUL IF IT ACTUALLY GETS OUT
ON THE STREET AND RESULTS. IN
MORE CLEAN VEHICLES. REPLACING A
DIRTY VEHICLES BECAUSE- THE
LONGER EIGHTY- CARBON PRODUCING
VEHICLE IS OFF THE ROAD- AND
CONVERSELY A CLEAN VEHICLES ON
THE ROAD. THE MORE BENEFIT WE
GET FROM IT GOING FORWARD SO
IT'S MUCH BETTER FOR US TO
ACHIEVE. THAT BENEFIT TO IT AND
IT'S TWO OR THREE OR FOUR YEARS
FROM NOW AND I. THINK THAT'S
SORT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO IT
A CHEATER BY. ACCELERATING THE
FUNDING- IT DOES RAISE THE
QUESTION IF THESE PROGRAMS. ARE
OVER SAYS SUCH RIGHT NOW. AND WE
SPEND OUR THIS MY- IN THE NEAR
TERM WILL THERE BE FUNDING IN
THE FUTURE. TO CONTINUE THE
PROGRAMS THERE'S- CERTAINLY SOME
UNCERTAINTY THERE BUT- I CAN SEE
THE BENEFIT OF. SPENDING THE
MONEY NOW- A BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE RECEIVING
TODAY. WITH THAT IF THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND MOVE
ON TO OUR- LAST TO WIN MORE
PRINT. THAT WAS OUR LAST. THANK
YOU MAY. WE WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW IF THERE ARE-
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING ROOM
. WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE STEP UP WE
WILL BE LIMITED PUBLIC COMMENT
TO ONE MINUTE. AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF A NUMBER OF CLIENTS HERE IN
TODAY- TO TALK SPECIFICALLY ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION B. C. P. THREE QUICK
ISSUES OUR FIRST WE'VE TALKED
WITH- DPR ABOUT SOME LANGUAGE IN
THERE REGARDING THE INSPECTION
OF DOCUMENTS FOR THE PESTICIDE
RESIDUE WE LIKE TO SEE THAT
TIGHTENED UP SO IT'S CLEAR THAT
IT'S REALLY DIRECTLY RELATED TO
HOSE INSPECTIONS IN THOSE
ENFORCEMENT ITEMS HI THE SECOND
ONE IS THAT. WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE IDEA OF FINES BEING
RAISED FOR INFLATIONARY PURPOSES
WE THINK THAT SHOULD BE THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE LEGISLATURE WE
KIND OF UNDERSTAND FEES BEING
UNDERSTOOD A REYES ON
INFLATIONARY REASONS BUT FINDS
NOT WE DON'T SUPPORT THE IDEA OF
THEM BEING REYES JUST FOR
INFLATIONARY PURPOSES WOULD LIKE
SIDE OF OVERSIGHT OVER THAT THE
THIRD AND FINAL ELEMENT IS WE
BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE SOME
ALTERNATIVE COMPLIANCE LANGUAGE
ALLOWED FOR AT THE- I
COMMISSIONER LEVEL ESPECIALLY
FOR SOME OF THOSE- ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS THAT COULD BE IMPROVED
OVER TIME WITH ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION AND TRAINING AND
BELIEVE THAT THAT SHOULD BE
WORKED INTO THIS B. C. P. LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
DEPARTMENT ON THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
LOW MEMBERS PAUL MASON WITH
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST I WAS THE
TO THE- THE NATURE BASED
SOLUTION PACKAGE- VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF SEEING WITH THAT
LEVEL OF INVESTMENT BUT WOULD
REALLY- LOOK TO THE LEGISLATURE
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE ROBUST-
CONDITION OF THE BUDGET. MAKE
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE INVESTMENT
THERE ALONG THE LINES WITH THE
SENATE HAS PROPOSED PERHAPS- AND
I WILL ALSO HIGHLIGHT WHAT THE
L. A. O. HAD POINTED OUT THAT
REALLY LOOKING AT WHAT SOME OF
OUR GOALS ARE LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
THIRTY BY THIRTY THAT SIX
MILLION ACRES IN THE NEXT EIGHT
YEARS. HOW DO THE INVESTMENTS
ACTUALLY SCALE TO GETTING US
THERE THAT WOULD CALL FOR A
LEVEL OF INVESTMENT DRAMATICALLY
HIGHER THAN WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THE CURRENT DISCUSSION SO.
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO AROUND
THOSE UP SUBSTANTIALLY AND TAKE
A HOLISTIC INTEGRATED APPROACH
THAT A WATERSHED SCALE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MR
MEMBERS ON FURTHER OF ON THE ON
BEHALF TREAT PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
AND TRUST. SPECIFIC TO ITEM TWO
ON EXTREME HEAT AND SCHOOL
GREENING- I WON'T REPEAT WHAT'S
ALREADY BEEN SAID I THINK WAS A
GREAT DISCUSSION. REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ARTICULATION OF-
AB TWO FIVE SIX SIX BYE BYE
MISTER BENNETT- AND MISS RIVAS-
REALLY THERE'S A PRETTY GOOD
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO MOVE
FORWARD- A GOOD FRAMEWORK. FOR
HOW YOU MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS
FOR OUR SCHOOLS- THROUGH THE
URBAN FORESTRY PROGRAM AND- AS
WAS JUST STATED WOULD LIKE TO
SEE ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATIONS
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT THAT WE KNOW-
ARE CRITICALLY NEEDED- THE LAST
THING I'LL MENTION IS THAT THAT.
PROPOSAL HAS. BEEN VERY WELL
COORDINATED AND HAS TAKEN A LOT
OF EFFORT- INCLUDING WORKING
WITH L. A. U. S. T. WHO I KNOW
WILL BE SPEAKING AFTER ME BUT- I
WANT TO MENTION THAT A LOT OF
GOOD WORK AS A HAS ALREADY BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED. IN THAT PROPOSAL
AND IF WE THINK ABOUT IT MERRY'S
VERY WELL WITH THE WITH PROPOSAL
BEFORE YET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MAJOR WOMEN MEMBERS SOCIAL
HOROWITZ WITH THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT ON ITEM
TO- UST GREATLY APPRECIATES THE
LEGISLATORS COMMITMENT TO
INVESTING IN NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS FOR MITIGATING THE
IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT AND
SCHOOLYARDS. PARTICULARLY IN
URBAN AREAS WITH THE HIGHEST
NUMBERS OF DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS. FROM PREVIOUS STATED.
INVESTMENTS L. UFT HAVE LEARNED
THAT TO BE IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVELY. THESE GREEN
PROJECTS MUST INVOLVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHOSE CAMPUSES WILL BE
IMPACTED. IN IMPROVED FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE PROCESS. WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT THE APPROACH
THAT FORWARD IN TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY SIX THAT WOULD THAT STOP
WHICH IS A PROCESS TO ENSURE THE
PROJECTS ARE FEASIBLE.
APPROPRIATELY SCOPED AND HAVE
BUY IN FROM THE DISTRICT ALSO
FACILITATING GENUINE
PARTNERSHIPS TO BUILD ON THE
EXPERTISE OF LOCAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS READ AT US ON BEHALF OF
THE STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION AND
CERTIFIED LOCAL CONSERVATION
CORES IN SUPPORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BCP ARE NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS IN GENERAL WE
THINK IT MEETS THE COMMITMENT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE MADE LAST YEAR
AND THAT COVERS A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
FOR THE STATE IN PARTICULAR
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE-
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP THAT THE
BCP SHOWS WITH THE LOCAL CORES.
AS YOU WELL KNOW OUR PROP SIXTY
FUNDING IS OUT AND WITH THIS B.
C. P. WOULD BE PROPERLY-
IMPLEMENTED AS THE MINISTRATION
AS SUGGESTING IT WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE TO CONTINUE TO PARTNER
WITH RECORDS AND ALLOW US
DEVELOP CONSERVATION PROJECTS IN
IT AND ALL THE DISTRICTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACT COMMISSIONERS IN
STEELERS ASSOCIATION I'M
SPEAKING TO ITEM NUMBER THREE ON
THE B. C. P. FOR ENFORCEMENT
WITH DPR WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH DPR AND
COLLECTIVELY- IN FORCING THESE
ARE VARIOUS ACTIONS THAT WE'RE
TAKING ON- BUT ALSO IN RESPECT
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER FUNG'S
COMMENTS IN THAT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ALONE OUR COMMISSIONERS
AND THEIR STAFF PERFORMED OVER
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND INSPECTIONS
ACROSS THE STATE WITH A NINETY
EIGHT POINT 2% COMPLIANCE RATE
SO COMMISSIONER DOWN THERE STAFF
ARE IN THE FIELD ACTIVELY
WORKING. TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF
THESE LAWS REGULATIONS ARE BEING
COMPLIED WITH AND WANT TO
CONTINUE THAT ENFORCEMENT OUR
COMMISSIONERS A COOK REGULARLY
COLLABORATE WITH EACH OTHER IN
VARIOUS COUNTIES IN APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH CPR
ON THAT AS WELL AND SO- WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF A POTENTIAL-
WORKING WITH INDUSTRY AND
LOOKING AT SOME ALTERNATE
COMPLIANCE AND WORKING THROUGH-
YOU KNOW OUR STRUCTURE AND
MAKING NOT POSSIBLE AS WELL LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS TO STRENGTHEN OUR
PARTNERSHIP IN THE ENFORCEMENT
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR ABACA
MARKETS REPRESENTING AMERICAN
FARMLAND TRUST CARBON CYCLE
INSTITUTE IN THE CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED ORGANIC FARMERS
SPEAKING TO ISSUE ONE. I'D FIRST
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM
AS AND HIS ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITMENT TO CLIMATE CHANGE
SOLUTIONS. AND THE IMPORTANT
ROLE OF NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS. A HUGE THANK YOU TO UNDER
SECRETARY HANSON FOR HER
TIRELESS WORK IN OUR OPEN FOR
POLICY FOR ALL OF US
STAKEHOLDERS. ALL THAT BEING
SAID WERE DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
BCP BEFORE US DOESNOT INCLUDE
MORE INVESTMENTS IN THE WORKING
LAND SECTOR. FARMERS AND
RANCHERS WANT TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION BUT WE NEED AN
INCENTIVES AND RESOURCES TO DO
SO. SPECIFICALLY WE LIKED AT THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
AGRICULTURAL LAND CONSERVATION
ACCESS. CROPLANDS ARE MISSING
FROM THE LAND TYPES WHICH CAN
ACCESS CONSERVATION DOLLARS IN
THE B. C. P. WE URGE YOU TO FIND
THE CALIFORNIA FIRMLY
CONSERVANCY PROGRAM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD LIKE
INVESTMENTS TO THE ALTERNATIVE
MANURE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
PRESCRIBED GRAZING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE'RE IN OUR
AND ORGANIC TRANSITION PROGRAMS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND SET
ASIDE FOR PROGRAM EVALUATION OF
THE CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE
PROGRAMS. CDFA WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE OUR ARE CONTINUING
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THIS.
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS ERICA
ROMERO ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
BASED ORGANIZATIONS FRIENDS OF
THE L. A. RIVER NATURE FOR ALL
AND COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION.
WE ARE ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BI C. P. FOR
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
PARTICULARLY THE PROPOSED A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION OVER
TWO YEARS FOR STATE
CONSERVANCY'S WILL BE CRUCIAL
REGION SPECIFIC. CONSERVATION
PROJECTS STATEWIDE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH THE
RESOURCES AGENCY TO ACHIEVE THE
WORTH. OF CONSERVING 30% OF
LANDS BY TWENTY THIRTY AND WE
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
FULL PROPOSAL WHEN THE TIME
COMES. SECONDLY ON BEHALF OF THE
L. A. NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSED
A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. IN THE GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS PROGRAM IN THE
EXTREME HEAT PACKAGE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ELAINE ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF THE
NRDC ACTION FUND IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATIONS BCP. AND
ACCOMPANYING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REGARDING THE PESTICIDE
USE ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM. WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO ALLOCATE
FUNDING FOR DPR IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO INVESTIGATE
AND DEVELOP PESTICIDE
ENFORCEMENT CASES. TO REACTIVATE
DPR STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE PESTICIDE USE
VIOLATIONS. AND TO ADOPT A LONG
OVERDUE INCREASE AND THE MAXIMUM
PENALTIES FOR PESTICIDE USE
VIOLATIONS AND PESTICIDE SALES
AND LICENSING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING TURNMEMBERS
ABIGAIL MILE ON BEHALF OF SAVE
THE REDWOODS LEAGUE SEMPERVIRENS
FUND MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT AND THE LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
SPEAKING TO ITEM ONE ON THE
AGENDA WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE SIGNIFICANT CONSERVATION
INVESTMENTS INCLUDED IN THE
NATUREBASED SOLUTIONS B. C. P.
AND A GRATEFUL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS PROPOSAL WE
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL GET THE STATE
PARK GOAL OF CONSERVING 30% OF
LANDS BY TWENTY THIRTY. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH
THE RESOURCES AGENCY TO TAKE
MEANINGFUL STEPS TO ACHIEVE THIS
WITH THAT WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ENERGY FORWARD YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS ITEM WHEN THE
TIME COMES. THANK THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD MORNING TO BERMAN
MEMBERS STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING COALITION.
OUR COALITION ADMINISTER STATE
AUTHORIZED NATURAL COMMUNITY
CONSERVATION PLANS AND FEDERALLY
AUTHORIZED HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANS. WHICH ARE KEYPARTNERS IN
THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO PROTECT
AND RESTORE CRITICAL HABITATS.
IN AREAS OF THE STATE THAT ARE
UNDER IMMENSE PRESSURE TO
DEVELOP LAND. THE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR PRESERVES
WILL ENSURE THAT WILDLIFE WILL
BE ABLE TO SURVIVE IN THE FACE
OF CHANGING CLIMATE AND WILL
HAVE THE WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
NECESSARY. TO FIND ADEQUATE
HABITAT IN THE FUTURE SO WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO CDFW FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF NCC PEAS IN
ACP'S. AND THAT NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS PACKAGE AND URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THAT
INVESTMENT WHEN IT IS BEFORE YOU
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING CHARMERS I'M TOM
KNOX AVELLA CLEANER NOW WE
MANAGED TO CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAM IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ON BEHALF OF THE VALLEY
ARE DISTRICT. BOB WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR THE PRIORITY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE PUT
ON CLEAN CAR FOR ALL IN THIS
BUDGET. WE SEE THE REAL WORLD
BENEFITS THAT COME FROM
REPLACING OLDER UNRELIABLE CARS
WITH NEWER PLUG IN VEHICLES. AS
OUR TEAM IS COMPLETED MORE THAN
FOUR THOUSAND THESE TRANSACTIONS
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN. NONE OF
THIS WOULD'VE BEEN POSSIBLE
WITHOUT THE STRONG SUPPORT OF
ALL PARTIES INVOLVED. WHAT WE
SUPPORT THE OVERALL. BUDGET
ALLOCATION FOR CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL WE DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE PROPOSED FUNDING SPLIT
BETWEEN THE FIVE DISTRICTS
CURRENTLY OPERATING. CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL AND THE NEW PROPOSED
STATEWIDE PROGRAM. IF THE
PRIORITY HERE IS TO EXPEDITE
MORE FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PURCHASES IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT MOST NEED TO
HELP. THE EXISTING PROGRAMS IN
THE FIVE AIR DISTRICTS WHICH
HAVE PROVEN TRACK RECORDS- ED
ARE HISTORICALLY OVERSUBSCRIBED-
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THIS THE
FOR EXAMPLE OUR CUSTOMER
APPLICATION RATE OVER THE PAST
TWO QUARTERS. WOULD SUPPORT AN
ANNUAL I SPENT A FIFTY TO SIXTY
MILLION IN THE SEVENTY DOLLAR
ALONE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE LEFT IN THE
ROOM. ALL RIGHT- WILL MOVE TO-
THOSE WHO ARE. AVAILABLE CALLING
IN OPERATOR YOU ARE YOU OUT
THERE. ABSOLUTELY IF YOU HAVE IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME IN
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND WE'LL CALL
WHEN IT'S OPEN. WE WILL FIRST GO
TO LINE THIRTY GO AHEAD. NINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DUKE COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
MOUNTAINS RECREATION AND
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE THIRTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING DANIEL BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL TO
ACCELERATE YOUR ADMISSION
VEHICLE AND FOR STRUCTURE
FUNDING. EVEN WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT AND
DEPLOYMENT OF CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN RECENT YEARS
RANGE ANXIETY DUE TO A LACK OF
CHARGING CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF
THE LARGEST BARRIERS TO THAT
ADOPTION. WITH A FIFTY TWO ROLE
MAKING SETTING OUT ON A PATH
TOWARD THE 100% THAT SCALED BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. THE STATE
MUST DO AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE TO OVERCOME THE
SPARE. THEREFORE THE PROPOSAL TO
ACCELERATE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
PERCENT INFRASTRUCTURE AND THREE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR EQUITABLE
HOME CHARGING IS OF PARAMOUNT.
IS THAT PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE.
FURTHER THIS STAGE ALSO. MAKE
SURE THAT THIS TRANSITION TO
DETERMINE FUTURE. AND INCLUDES
FRONT COMMUNITIES FOR THAT
REASON WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO FAST TRACK FUNDING
FOR EQUITY THOUGHT FOCUSED
PROGRAMS SUCH AS CREDIT CARDS
FOR ALL. AND COMMUNITY ZERO
EMISSION MOBILITY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. PINE.
TWELVE HI ONE OF THEM IS NOT
AWARE THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND-
WE ARE AWARE SPEAKING FOR ON
ITEM TO WEAR GRATEFUL FOR THE
QUEEN WELL YOUR- BUT BUT WE
THINK THAT A TWO HUNDRED BILLION
. APPROPRIATE IS- A BETTER
AMOUNT OUT TO FUND THE SCHOOL
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
NEXT YEAR WE'RE GOING TO PULL
JEFF YARDS CAN MAKE AN IMMEDIATE
COST EFFECTIVE DIFFERENCE- IN
OVER A HUNDRED SCHOOLS ACROSS
THE STATE DIRECTLY BENEFITING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS
IF FOCUSED ON DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE LITTLE
ACCESS TO PARK WE CANNOT BE THE
BENEFIT TO SCHOOL CHILDREN OF
CLEANING WELL WE ARE- ARE
ABIDING CLEAR IN THE CAR-TO IN
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT PUTTING.
WINTER CAP WITH A RELATIVELY LOW
WITH HIGH IMMEDIATE BENEFIT. TO
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE FORTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON YOU TURN
ESPECIALLY HARD WORKING STAFF
THIS DANIEL GLEASON CAMP WITH
THE CALIFORNIANS FOR
BIODIVERSITY SPEAKING CRIED ONE
AND ITEM THREE. WE WISH TO
EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSED NATURAL BASED SOLUTIONS
AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO BE BOLD AS
YOU PLAN INVESTMENT BUT REGAINED
CALIFORNIA'S STATUS AS A LEADER
IN CLIMATE ESPECIALLY
BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION. WE
SPECIFICALLY ASK YOUR EXPAND ON
THE SENATE PROPOSAL INCREASING
FUNDING BY FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THIRTY BY THIRTY AND THREE
BILLION FOR COASTAL WORK AND IT
CAN BE LEVERAGING A GREAT TOOLS
THAT YOU ALREADY HAVE SUCH AS
WTB A CONSERVANCY. AS WELL AS
BUILDING NEW CAPACITY AND
ADVANCING EQUITY BY SUPPORTING
NONPROFIT CBO CONTRIVES. WE ALSO
ASK THAT YOU LISTEN TO WHAT ON
THE GROUND TRYING TO SAY THEY
NEED INCLUDING IN THE THIRTY BY
THIRTY SCIENCE NEEDS REPORT. AN
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE SAVING THE
FUNDAMENTAL INFRASTRUCTURE BY
DIVERSITY WORKS BY INVESTING IN
BADGE MAPPING AND SECURING BIO
REPOSITORIES IN OREGON
COLLECTIONS SPEND FUNDING SOIL
BIODIVERSITY DNA BARCODING. TO
DISDAIN SOIL HEALTH CARBON
STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOUR BUDGET AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HARD WORKING AMBITIOUS
ACTION. WE ALSO WISH TO EXPRESS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR ITEM THREE
DVRS PROPOSED PESTICIDE USE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM BUDGET
TRAILER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANKS
FOR THE SHOUT OUT TO STAFF. NINE
FIFTY ONE. I'LL ASK YOUR MANAGER
CARE MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
CAN ALSO THANKING STAFF AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
WILDLIFE FEDERATION AN OUTLINE
FEDERATION APPLE SUPPORT AND
GRATITUDE FOR THE TO LIBERTY
CANYON ITEMS INVOLVING THAT THE
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WERE WILL FINISH THE
PROJECT AND FOR THE PROPOSED
BUDGET BUILDING WHICH TO BE
APPROPRIATE THE MONEY TO
CALTRANS LAST YEAR TO EXPAND
THEIR SPENDING AUTHORITY THERE
WHICH REALLY JUST WONDERFUL.
MINUTES ARE BASELESS TO CONTINUE
TO SHOW SUCH CONTINUED STRONG
SUPPORT FOR WELL THE CORRIDOR
AND CLAPPING WORK IN THE STATE
AND THEN LASTLY ON BEHALF OF
OCCIDENTAL ART IN THE QUALITY
CENTER DIFFERENT YOU ON EDGE
AGAIN ON ISSUE ONE DAY HOW MUCH
WE HOPE TO SEE- THIRTY BY THIRTY
THAT MEANS THAT THEY TAKE AS
MANY OPPORTUNITIES AS POSSIBLE
TO LEAN ON DIVERSE TO HELP. US
REACH OUR GOAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BY FORTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PASSIONATE MEN
ON OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REPORT CONSERVATION DISTRICT
AND THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
LAND TRUSTS- HERE SPEAKING ON
ISSUE ONE TODAY- WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR
EXPENDITURE PLANS FOR NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS. AND WE ARE VERY
HAPPY THAT THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT TOWARD THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND THE STATE
CONSERVANCIES HOWEVER WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THAT FUNDING COULD
AND SHOULD BE INCREASE. GIVEN
THE THIRD CLASS IN ADDITION WE
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
PROPOSED CLIMATE SMART LAND
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WILL PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED FUNDING FOR
ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING THIS FUNDING WILL HELP
LAND TRUSTS AND RCTS IMPLEMENT
THE GOAL OF THIRTY BY THIRTY AND
THE CLIMATE SMART STRATEGY. WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO APPROVE
THIS INVESTMENTS WHICH WILL
RESULT IN A CREEK PROTECTED. AND
RESTORED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY SIX. BLOOMIN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'M ALLEN APPS
WITH THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT SPEAKING ON
ISSUES REPORT THAT THAT PACKAGE
ELEVATION WELL WE ARE GENERALLY
SUPPORT IF WE KNOW THAT THE
STATEWIDE EXPANSION PROPOSAL FOR
THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAMS
CREATE THE COMPETING PROGRAMS IN
THE FIVE THEIR DISTRICTS ALREADY
ADMINISTERING BETWEEN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAM RATHER THAN JUST
PROVIDING NEEDS THEIR DISTRICT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS. THAT COULD CREATE
CONFUSION AMONG APPLICANTS WITH
DIFFERENT OUTREACH AND DIFFERENT
ADMINISTRATIVE RESPONSIBILITY
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU LIVE IN
THE BAY AREA WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE DIRECTION
IN THE BUDGET TO REDUCE THIN
EFFICIENCY BY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING DIRECTLY TO
AIR DISTRICTS. OTHER THAN- A
COMPETING PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FIND THIRTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING SURE NUMBERS
MAKING CLEVELAND LOOK THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN THE CALLING TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE FUNDING
FURNITURE BASED SOLUTIONS
CALIFORNIA THIRTY BY THIRTY
INITIATIVE INVOLVED CONSERVING
SIX MILLION ACRES IN THE NEXT
EIGHT YEARS CONESUS TARGET THE
STATE NEEDS TO INVEST ONE
BILLION DOLLARS EVEN THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT IS
NEEDED THE GOVERNOR'S NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS BCP ALLOCATE
ONLY A PORTION OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT MILLION
TO PROTECT AN ACQUIRED LAND.
TEAM HE RECOMMENDS BUT THE
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS FUNDING
BE ALLOCATED TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND STATE
REGIONAL CONSERVANCY WHICH HAVE
A LONGSTANDING TRACK RECORD OF
EFFECTIVELY ADVANCING PROTECTION
AND SUPPORTING THE PUBLIC USE OF
NATURAL RESOURCES. YOU HAVE TO
RECOMMEND THAT THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION MULTI BENEFIT PLAN
TO REPURPOSE. THE PROGRAM.
SHOULD BE FUNDED THROUGH DROUGHT
PACKAGE. THE GOVERNOR'S TENURE
DROPPED. PROPOSAL INCLUDES FOR
THE PROGRAM AND WE RECOMMEND
ADDING THE DISH TWENTY NINE. TO
THE TROPICAL. FINALLY WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE MILLION
DOLLAR FOR FIRE'S. GREETING
PROGR BE FUNDED OUT OF THE
WILDFIRE AND FORCE RECENTLY
BUDGET PACKAGE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TAYLOR OCEAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS ATTACHED OF MY
COLLEAGUE LOUIS BROWN- AND WE'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE COMMENT ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE- AGRICULTURE HAS A
NINETY EIGHT POINT 4% COMPLIANCE
RATE WITH PESTICIDE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AND CALIFORNIA
PRODUCE CONTINUALLY AND
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED WITHIN
RESIDUE LIMITS- AND ARE ALSO
GOVERNED BY A UNIQUE AND HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE STRUCTURE WITH COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS SO
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS BASED ON
AN IMMEDIATE OR SERIOUS NEED.
AFTER THE INCREASED USE OF
ENFORCEMENT REGARDLESS WE LIKE
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH OTHERS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
OUR PRACTICAL CONCERNS ON
RESIDUE TESTING THE INFLATIONARY
COMPONENT AND PROPOSING-
FLEXIBILITY FOR NON MONETARY
BASE PENALTIES FOR MINOR AN
INTENTIONAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AT. NINE FIFTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRIS CHAVEZ I'M WITH
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AS PART
OF THE CHARGE AHEAD CALIFORNIA
INVEST IN CLEAN AIR CAMPAIGN ALL
COMMENTS DAY ARE ON ISSUE FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PACKAGE ACCELERATION. WE
SUPPORT ACCELERATING CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT MANY
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY OUR EQUITY PROGRAMS
HAVE LONG BEEN OVERSUBSCRIBED.
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
TRANSFORM INTO AUTOMOTIVE FLEET
PER METER CLIMB IN AIR QUALITY
COMMITMENTS WITHOUT REDUCING
BARRIERS TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. WITH THAT SAID
WE BELIEVE THAT THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE GOVERNR- THE GOVERNMENT'S
SUPPOSED TO BROOKLYN CARDS FOR
ALL PROGRAM NEEDS TO BE FLIPPED.
WE HAVE TO LEGISLATURE TO
ALLOCATE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TO EXISTING CLEAN CARTS
FOR ALL PROGRAMS WHICH HAVE AN
IMMEDIATE NEED WE WILL THE MEDIA
BENEFITS COULD FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S FUTURE STATEWIDE
EXPANSION. PLEASE FIFTY PROGRAMS
OF THE FEDERAL YOU PLAY
THOUSANDS OF DIRTY VEHICLES AND
SOME OF OUR MOST POLLUTED
REGIONS AND WITHIN TWO WEEKS THE
EXPAND TO SAN DIEGO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER CARE
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
COALITION AND AN RTC ACTION FUND
BEING AN ITEM TO THE EXTREME TV
PACKAGE BRENT THE PART OF THE
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
PROPOSED FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTER AS A GREAT
FIRST STEP TOWARDS FUNDING OUR
LARGER REQUEST FOR ONE BILLION
DOLLARS TO CONSTRUCT AN UPGRADE
COMMUNITY RESIGNED CENTER OF
BLACKPOOL'S LIBRARIES AND OTHER
PUBLIC FACILITIES. THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK ON THE BUDGET
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU MARK. THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY ONE. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS LAUREN KIÞM I'M CALLING
FROM THE L. A. LINE BRING YOUR
CALLING ME ECHOING THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CLIMATE RESILIENCE CENTERS
ON WE WOULD ALSO HOPE TO SEE THE
FINAL- COVERED BY BUILDING
TRAINS LABOR STANDARDS BUT THEY
ARE ADDITIONALLY CREATING GOOD
JOBS AS WELL AS MUCH NEEDED-
CLIMATE AND RESILIENCE
INVESTMENTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WHAT ALSO ECHO THE ADDRESS
AND ADDITIONAL FUNDS UP TO ONE
MILLION DOLLARS OR GREATER TO
MEET THAT THE RIGHT SCALE OF THE
- FOR THESE KIND OF UPGRADE THEN
YOU INVESTMENT IN OUR COMMUNITY. YOU THANK YOU. WELL MINE. NINE
SEVENTY. THANK YOU MISTER CARE
MEMBERS DANIEL MOORE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF BOMBING CALIFORNIA
PART OF THE CHARGE AHEAD CALL A
CALIFORNIA ISSUE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE SOME OF
THE WORK CARE COORDINATION WITH
A BUDGET SURPLUS SURPLUS
FORECASTED FOR THIS YEAR
CALIFORNIA THE CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN CLEAN
AIR WE SUPPORT OF TELLING THE
FUNDING FOR DEBT CHARGING
ANYTHING CREDIBLE FACT AFFECTED
CLEAN CAR EQUITY PROGRAMS
CALCULATION ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION FOR TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECTS. LIKELY CARD FOR
ALL AND THE FIFTEEN BOOKING ME
BATES TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS WE
SHOULD ALSO INVEST FOUR POINT
EIGHT BILLION FOR THE ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF
ROAD EQUIPMENT AND TWO BILLION
FOR THE COLD TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM AND OTHERS YOUR MISSION
CHARGING SUPPORT TO ENSURE
EXPANDED ACT WITH THE CHARGING
STATION EXPRESSLY AT OR NEAR
MULTI FAMILY HOMES IN ADDITION
IT IS OUR VIEW THAT CLEAN CARS
ALL WORKS BEST WHEN IT'S BEING
INITIATED. BY THE LOCAL LEVEL BY
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT'S THREE RECOMMEND THAT
THEY CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THE
MAJORITY OF THE FUNDS MOVING
FORWARD TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THEIR DISTINGUISHED SHIPS WITH
LOCAL GROUPS AND ABILITY TO READ
THOSE THAT. NEED IT MOST THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
GOING TO. I'M THE MEMBER- IN
THE- ROOM AT- THIS MOM. TO TAKE
A SO GOING TO REACH FOR TWO OR
MINUTES I'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
PROBABLY THE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
OPERATOR YOU MAY CONTINUE. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO NEXT TO LINES
SEVENTY TWO GO AHEAD. SHARE THIS
EMAIL RUSSIA FROM THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION TALKING
SPEAKING ON ITEM FOUR- WE
SUPPORT THE OVERALL FOCUS ON
CLIENT AIR. QUALITY AND EQUITY
PROGRAMS THAT PRIORITIZE LONG
HELD OUR STATE OF THE AIR REPORT
FOUND THAT TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS
AND TOO MANY DAYS. WITH
UNHEALTHY AIR IN THIS YEAR'S
REPORT WHICH WAS WHICH CAME OUT
LAST WEEK LAST MONTH WE FOUND
THAT SIX CALIFORNIA CITIES
RANKED TOP TEN OZONE IN THE U.
S. AND SEVEN CALIFORNIA CITIES
THAT. ARE AT THE TOP TEN FOR
PARTICLE POLLUTION LOS ANGELES
RANKS NUMBER ONE IN THE NATION
FOR THE WORST OZONE. AND IN FACT
LA WE THOUGHT WE HAVE NOT SEEN
OZONE DAYS HI SEN R. TWENTY TEN
REPORT FOR THESE REASONS WE-
NEED TO MOVE QUICKLY TO
TRANSITION VEHICLES OF THEIR OWN
MISSION WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CELEBRATE
THEIR MISSION TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS ESPECIALLY EQUITY.
BASED PROGRAMS TO ACHIEVE THESE
GOALS- WE FAVOR SHIFTING A LARGE
OF THE EQUITY BASICALLY BE CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL FUNDING TO
DISTRICTS TO FIND NICK FIXING
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSIONS FOR
COMMUNITIES. THAT NEED IT THE
MOST THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MATTHEW ALLEN WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION-
WANTED TO- TOUCH FIND ITEM
NUMBER THREE- WE HAVE- SOME
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSED DPR AT TRAILER BILL AND
WE WOULD SIMPLY ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS- WITH THOSE MADE BY- IS
RUSSIAN AND MISTER BROWN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. TWENTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHIRTLESS MAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JAMIE MERRILL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CLIMB INTO
AGRICULTURE NETWORK WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE WORKING THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS ADMINISTRATION
TO ADVANCE NATURAL LOOKING LAND
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS THE NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS INCLUDE CRITICAL
FUNDING FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CONSERVATION MORE HOWEVER THERE
ARE SOME IMPORTANT VETERINARIANS
THAT ARE MISSING INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA FARM LAND CONSERVANCY
PROGRAM INVESTMENTS IN LAND ACT
HAVE BEEN TENURE TRIBAL
CONSULTATION ON PROTECTING ACT
LANDS WE OPEN SUPPORT PROGRAM
EVALUATION OF THE CDFA CLIMATE
SMART AGRICULTURE GRAMS. FUNDING
FOR PRESCRIBED RAISING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BETTER MEET
THE DEMANDS OF WILDFIRE
PREVENTION THROUGH GRAZING
MANAGEMENT FUNDING FOR ECONOMIC
TRANSITION BACK HE'S TRACKING
OUTLINED IN THE NEW DRAFT
SCOPING PLAN AND FUNDING FOR
METHANE EMISSION REDUCTION
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH THE
ALTERNATE MIDDLE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM FINALLY FARMWORKERS
SAFETY IS MISSING- FROM THE
EXTREME HEAT B. C. P. AND WE
NEED TO INVEST IN FORMER HOUSING
AND HOME WEATHER STATION OTHER
PROTECTIONS FOR THESE ESSENTIAL
FRONTLINE. WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE FORTY. I THINK
YOU CARE THE TIME IN ON THE OF
THE HYDROGEN COUNCIL I'M
COMMENTING ON ITEM FOUR ZERO
EMISSION. ACCELERATION PACKAGE
WE'RE THE OF THERE ARE VEHICLE
FOR I'M PRETTY ALL FIELD AFTER
FUN WOULD YOU WANT A HIGH THAT
C. E. NINE HUNDRED NO THAT WOULD
A COLOR AT THE PHYSICALLY FOR
BATTERY VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
REPUBLICAN AT HOME CHARGING
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE FIND
VERY PROBLEMATIC BILLS ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE WONDERFUL POLLUTION
COMING IN OUR DECARBONISATION
AND AIR QUALITY COLD THEY HAVE
LONG RANGE QUICK REFUELING VERY
RELIABLE CARS AND ACCESSIBLE TO
THE PUBLIC AT REGULAR GAS
STATION. WOULD LOVE TO SEE MORE
INVESTMENT IF YOU'LL COLLECTOR
VEHICLES UNTIL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
ALLOCATIONS FOR THEIR EMISSION
VEHICLES SHOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
WITH PARITY BETWEEN BATTERY
ELECTRIC AND FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND WE HOPE TO SEE THEM
VESTMENTS. QUICKLY BETWEEN THE
TWO TECHNOLOGY. THANK YOU. AT
NINE TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU CHEN
MEMBERS DISABILITY EXCITEMENT
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE TWO AND
FOUR IF YOU TO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
RESILIENCE CENTERS WHICH ARE A
CRITICAL PIECE OF PHYSICAL AND
SOCIAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND ARE
INSTRUMENTAL IN BUILDING
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE BUT DURING
ACUTE EXTREME CLIMATE EVENTS AND
IN THE LONG TERM. EXCITED TO SEE
THE FUNDING IN THE BUDGET I'M
ALL WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR A
TOTAL OF ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO
MEET THE STATE LIKE SCALABILITY
FOR RESILIENCE CENTERS THE
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
ALLOCATION IS A CRUCIAL PART. I
THANK YOU FOR. XCELERATED THAT'S
- AS PROGRAMS LIKELY COULD. CAR
FOR ALL IN MUCH NEEDED MAKE THAT
CUSTOMER WELCOME HOW. WERE
HARMED IN THE I GOT RIGHT THAT.
MAKING SENSE ACCEPTABLE TE
NEXT. TO MAKE. SEVEN EACH YEAR
REDUCTION TARGET. THE PROGRAMS
INCLUDED IN THE DOES EXCEL. OUR
ALL CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT
HELP NEEDS THAT GOLD AND- AT. I
DID WE STRONGLY URGED. WITH
COMMUNITY AND- VERIFIABLE
PROGRAMS TO MEET THESE KIND OF
CALLS VIDEOS IN SOME. AT A.
CONSUMERS NAVIGATE PROCESS YOU
ARE SEVEN SENTENCE AND WORKING
THE DEALS WILL HELP ENSURE THAT.
WRITTEN ENTERED YOU CAN'T ACT
RECEIVE BENEFITS THE PROGRAMS
LIKE THE HUSKY ALL. FINALLY AND
WE WERE TO ENSURE THE ALL THAT
INTO. BUT PRIOR ELITE I WOULD
HAD THIS FEELING STATION FAKE.
AND IN THAT I DID TO BE. THANK.
THANK YOU VERY. PINE SIXTY ONE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTER- MY NAME IS
JOHN MARKET RESEARCH FROM
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK KOREANS
OF ITEM THREE CARS RECIPIENT
TRAILER BILL FOR NEARLY FORTY
YEARS REBOUNDED ADVOCATED FOR
BETTER PROTECTIONS FOR
FARMWORKERS FROM PESTICIDE
EXPOSURE AND THE WELL DOCUMENTED
NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS OF THAT
EXPOSURE TO DATE APR OR A
COMMISSIONER'S INSPECTIONS OF
DOCUMENTED VIOLATIONS OF MORE
THAN 50% OF WORKER PROTECTION
INSPECTIONS YET USEPA DATA
SHOWED THAT LESS THAN 10% OF
THOSE. RESULT IN ANYTHING MORE
THAN A MERE WARNING REGARDING
PENALTIES THEY TEND TO BE
EXTREMELY LOW CREATING NO REAL
INCENTIVE TO FOLLOW THE LAW WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY PROVIDED
IN THIS BUDGET THAT WOULD ALLOW
DPR TO SUPPORT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO DO A BETTER JOB
AND IN OTHER WAYS LIKE IMPROVING
REPORTING TO SUPERIORS WERE
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED THE NEED TO
PROTECT THE STATE'S WHAT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FARMWORKERS THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. ABOUT HALF OF THE
VIOLATIONS RESULT IN PESTICIDE
DRIFT THAT MOVED OFF SITE
CONTAMINATING NEARBY HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
LINE SIXTY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN GAVE HER A
DETECTIVE TO TWO FOUR OTHER
TECHNOLOGY AND VENTURA. FOR A
PARTICULARLY AS ONE TO PRO HELP
TO TOXIC PRESS TO TRYING IN FACT
BECAUSE AND BY. IN ORDER TO MEET
. FOR ALL CARGO SAID AS
AMBITIOUS GOAL OF PERCENT
ORGANIC ACREAGE BY TWENTY THIRTY
NOT TWENTY FORTY FIVE OR- EIGHT.
SB FIVE OF NOT BOOKS BECAUSE- AT
. ON WERE WHILE. WE ARE SUPPORT
THE FOR IMPROVED FOR MITIGATION
AND- STRONGLY SUPPORT ISSUES.
AND INCREASE ADMINISTER ALMOST
OF CIVIL PENALTIES PESTICIDE
BIOLASE- AND AT THE AND THE
ISSUE TELL MITIGATED HI I WAS.
OF THAT ALL CAN BY DIVERSE WHICH
- PERFECT FOR WELL- IT.
IT HARBURY CONSIDERATION FOR
FARMWORKERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY EIGHT.
GLOBAL FLEAS NINE FIFTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR SHARING COMMITTEE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE AMONG THE
GREEN LINE INITIATIVE- COMMON
ISSUE FOR INSTRUCTABLES THAT THE
READING EQUITY INVESTMENTS
WITHIN THE TECH PACKAGE YOUR
SUPPORT WILL DEMONSTRATE THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO EQUITY A
PYROTECHNIC DIRECTED MEDICAL
BENEFITS THE DISADVANTAGED AND
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES HOW DID
PROGRAMS ARE AND HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING BENEFITS BOTH
SOCIOECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES BY IMPROVING
ACCESS AFFORDABILITY AND A
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT. I BY THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND YEAH
RESEARCH REPORT PROGRAMS THAT
CAN CARDS FROM THE FINANCES
HELLO THE CAME ABILITY PROGRAM
ARE NOT TO OVER SINCE BUT
THEY'VE UNDER FIRE FOR YOU AND
ARE IN NEED THIS WITH FUNDING
PUBLIC THAT SENT THIS- BY
PRIORITY BUT- I WILL BELIEVE
THAT WHEN IT COMES CAN CARP FOR
ALL WHICH FIRST BUY. FUNDING
CLEAN CAR SPA PROGRAM THAT BY
DISTRICTS NEVER ALLOCATE TO HER
MILLION FOR EVERY TEST AND
REMAINING VICTIMS FOR STATE WIDE
X. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PINE
CREEK FIVE. COULD GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS A SITES AND I URGE
YOU JUST I THROUGH PASSED THE
AND FOR. I WORKED AS AN INTERN
WITH COUNTY AGRA COMMISSIONER
FOR YEARS AND WORKED DEEP CARES
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH FOR EIGHT
YEARS BASED ON MY PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE I SUPPORT ALL
ELEMENTS OF THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDING DPR STAFF POSITIONS
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY AND
MAXIMUM FINE LEVELS. REGARDING
FINE LEVELS MOST PESTICIDE USERS
FOLLOW SAFETY RULES BUT THE
REALITY IS THE POSSIBILITY OF
FINES IS NEEDED TO DETERMINE AT
ACTORS THAT'S JUST THE WAY THE
WORLD WORKS REMEMBER THESE ARE
MAXIMUM FINES WHICH TYPICALLY
WOULD BE RESERVED FOR THE MOST
EGREGIOUS VIOLATIONS INCLUDING A
PATTERN OF REPEAT VIOLATIONS
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT TO IMPOSE
THE MAXIMUM FINE TO SIMPLY GIVE
THAT COMMISSIONERS AND DPR MORE
EFFECTIVE OPTIONS. SWITCHING TO
THE TOPIC OF DPR THIRTY FOR
DOCUMENTS ABOUT CONTAMINATED
PRODUCE LIKE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
CONCERNS OF A PREVIOUS SPEAKER
FROM INDUSTRY. BUT I URGE YOU TO
BE CAREFUL ABOUT LIMITING. TO
THE ONLY THAT. RELEVANT TO A
SINGLE SHIPMENT TO MENTION JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OTHER SHIPMENTS FROM
THE SAME SUPPLIER MIGHT ALSO
NEED TO BE EXAMINED. IN CLOSING
THE OPTION OF HIGHER FINES IS
NEEDED TO KEEP PACE WITH
INFLATION AND TO MAKE FIND
COMPARABLE TO THOSE ESTABLISHED
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL PLEASE
SUPPORT ALL ELEMENTS OF ITEM
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE SIXTY SIX
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI THIS IS
MICHAEL JARED ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS AND SUPPORT CDFA THE
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE-
EXPENDITURES INCLUDED IN THE
EXTREME HEAT BTP AND WE WILL
ALSO SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT OF SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CDFA IS BIOLOGICALLY
INTEGRATED FARMING SYSTEM
PROGRAM. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRE
FOR FOOD SAFETY IN SUPPORT OF
ITEM THREE DPR PROPOSAL FOR
INCREASED THAT PENALTIES AND
ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BEYOND A LITTLE BIT TO BELLY
PREVENT PROJECT THIS SENSE OF
COUNTY I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF ISSUE THREE PESTICIDE USE
APARTMENT PROGRAM AND TRAILER
BILL YOU MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW BUT
APPROXIMATELY 20% OF ALL THAT
STATUS IN THE COUNTRY HAPPENING
CALIFORNIA I'M THE COMMUNITIES
THAT SURROUND AGRICULTURE AND I
PREDOMINATELY PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED. THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OUR CREATED DEPENDS ON THE
STATE AGENCIES TO HOLD FARMERS
AND PESTICIDE APPLICATORS WITH
PEOPLE FOR ALL OF THAT IMPACT
OUR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
ASK YOU TO APPROVED DVRS REQUEST
AND THAT RELATES TO FIND WE TO
HOPE THAT THE ACT COMMISSIONERS
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
. USED THEIR AUTHORITY TO FIND
VIOLATORS OF APPROPRIATELY YES
ARE YOU REVIEW DPRK WEBSITE
REGARDING THE DECISION AND FINDS
WE SEE THREE HUNDRED AND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR FINDS THAT SEEM
LIKE A SLAP ON THE WRIST AND DO
NOT PREVENT REPEAT LIKE TRY CAL
AND RECENTLY- SUED OUT
HELICOPTER SERVICE. WE AND YOU
TO SUPPORT THE PEACE THREE PLUS
THANK. YOU THANK YOU. UNTIL
SEVEN. JERRY BROWN MAY STEVEN
CENTER BROWN'S HALF THE CAP I
DIDN'T COALITION SPEAKING TO
EACH FOR EXCEPT COLORATION WE
OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR'S THAT SPAN
PLAN BECAUSE IT FAILED TO CLOSE
THE GAP BETWEEN OUR GIVE GIVE A
STRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AND THE
PROJECTED DEMAND FOR FUEL CELL
AFTER THAT. HE TRIED LOCAL
SEARCH STRATEGY. THAT ORDER TO
GET OUR CLIMATE AND BETWEEN. TO
FIVE LIKE BE THAT THE FUEL CELL
. JUST THERE THEY AS DRY GOING
TO THE SCOPING AFTER THE L. OF
HIGH YOU TRUST. READ MUST BE AT
. AS TODAY'S CORNER GAS STATION.
AND YET THE PROPOSAL FOR YOU
CONTAINS NO FUNDING FOR HYDROGEN
FILLING INSTRUCTIONS THAT
DEDICATING NINE HUNDRED MILLION
SOLELY TO GET THE CHART. I DO
INDUSTRIES SEEKING THREE HUNDRED
MILLION TO BUILD A STATEWIDE
FEELING NETWORK HOUSING STATIONS
FORTY ONE MILLION VEHICLES AND A
PATH SPECIFICITY. THIS COULD BE
ACHIEVED BY DIVIDING THE
PROPOSAL FOR YOU BETWEEN
CHARGING AYE CHEN OR ALLOCATING
AN ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
CC TO FINISH THE FEELING THAT
WORK. ADDITIONALLY THE STATION
DIVIDED HAVE BEEN BEATEN TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS EVENLY
BETWEEN ELECTRIC CHARGING AND
HYDROGEN. THIS WINTER I DID HAVE
A STABLE FUNDING SOURCES WE WORK
NEAR TWENTY THIRTY FIVE GOALS
AND AT THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER. IN ADVANCE CLEAN SWEEP
REGULATIONS. WE'RE TO THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER THESE
ALTERNATIVES BUT ISSUE COMES UP
FOR EXAMPLE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THIRTY WE- GOOD
MORNING- AFTER- TREMBLING MY
DOCTOR KATHRYN DR PRESENTING
THAT FOR CHEMICAL TOXIC SAFETY
CINEMA SAGE GOLD THINKING THE
ITEM THREE WE GREW WITH THE
STAFF AND WE THIS TO AND L. A.
L. THAT IN OUR TO SHIP HIM
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENT. THIS
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE MAXIMUM
MAXIMUM PENALTIES IT'S IMPORTANT
AS WE AND WE SUPPORT IT STAFF
ALSO RECOMMENDED LISTENING TO
STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS FAMILIES
WITH CHILDREN ESPECIALLY IN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS ARE FOUND
FARMWORKERS WHO ARE 70% BUT NEXT
OUR STAKEHOLDERS AS OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS. THESE CONCERNS
ARE REAL J. SCHOOLS ARE PRIORITY
CUTBACKS AND STUFF EPR STATED
AGAIN IN TODAY'S HEARING BUT THE
SCHOOL SWAG THE PAIR REGULATIONS
ON ENFORCEABLE THESE REGULATIONS
MUST BE CORRECTED SO THEY CAN BE
ENFORCED IF THE STATE IS
INCREASING PENALTIES DANGER TO
SCHOOLS MUST BE A PRIORITY YOU
CAN'T UNDO AND EXPOSURE THEY'RE
ALL AN INTENTIONAL BUT STIFF
PENALTIES WILL ENCOURAGE GREATER
SAFETY. AND PREVENT REPEATED
EXPOSURES THANKS OF ALSO LIKE TO
UNDERSCORE THE NEED FOR FINES
AND PENALTIES FOR MAJOR TRIP
INCIDENTS. PUTS FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN AT RISK FOR EXPOSURE
ANDHOW AT PLAY. HELP WORKER
PICKED MUST BE INCLUDED FARMER
IMPACT OUT THE HOME WITH PETS ON
THEIR CLOTHES EXPOSING NOVEL
DENTURE BUT THEIR FOR TO DANGERS
AFTER FIVE AND HE'S GONNA
EXPOSURES ARCS TO HIGH RISK FOR
CHRONIC TO CANCER LAST WEEK I
RECALL COMMISSIONERS SHOULD BE
SUPPORTED IN THAT'S JUST THE
CREE OF A SERVICES TO ENSURE
ACCESS TO A PRESS. WHICH ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR FILING BRENDA BY
C. AS A SAMPLE. THANK YOU MADE
AN IN COURSE FUNDING BY MUST
ACCOUNT FOR ESPECIALLY FROM AND
THEIR FAMILIES WE SUPPORT THIS
IMPORT RECALLS. AND HELPS IT
WILL ADDRESS HE COULD DO BECAUSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NINE FOURTEEN. HELLO HONORED
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS
PROBABLY AND I'M CALLED MEMBER
AT THE SAME OF THE COMMISSION OR
CURRENTLY IN SERVICE PARTS AND
OPEN SPACE IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS. 222-025-2720 EIGHT AND TWENTY
NINE I'M HERE TO THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY OR
THEIR FUNDING PROPOSAL FOR
NATURE SEE SOLUTIONS AND I'M
SPECIFICALLY GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
PROPOSED LOCAL AND TRIBAL NATURE
C. SOLUTION COR. AT BENEFIT
COMPETITION CORPS I WORK
SPECIFICALLY ASKED IF CHELSEA
CARDMEMBER AND I'M EXCITED TO
SEE A PROPOSAL TO EXPAND FUNDING
FOR PROGRAMS LIKE THIS I
REGULARLY RIDE MY BIKE ON SHOWS
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA WITH MY
CREW I HELP THE COMMUNITY BY
CLEANING UP AT THE CREATURE
HAZARD SUPPORTING INAPPROPRIATE
ACTIVITIES ON THE CHANCE
THIRTIES ASSISTING FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS ON THE TRAIL WITH
ANY INFORMATION THEY NEED. I AM
EXCITED TO SEE THIS PROGRAM GROW
INTO SOMETHING BIGGER THANK YOU
ALL FOR EVERYTHING YOU. DO PARK
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. PINE FOR EIGHT. HELLO THIS IS
A RON WHITE HERE AND WITH- COME
OF RINCON BY TELL THEM EXACTLY
AS MY THE CARE IN TECH BOB AND
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF- IF- ONE
AND. TWO- BY SUPPORT EXPAND THE
DEEP- SCOPE AND- INCREASED- FINE
STRUCTURE. AND ON THE NATURE
BASED SO. WE WORK WITH EVERY DAY
SOUTH AND GET OFF OF TOXIC
PESTICIDES THE BASIC PRINCIPLE
OF ORGANIC IS THAT A HEALTHY
PLANT RESIST PESTS AND DISEASE
AND SO THE PROBLEM IS NOT ABOUT
THE PAST THE PROBLEM IS THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING HEALTHY PLANTS.
I ENCOURAGE- DPR ANOTHER
AGENCIES TO ACCEPT AGRO ECOLOGY
AND ECOLOGICAL APPROACH TO
FARMING. TO- ELIMINATE THE
VIRTUALLY THE NEED FOR ANY TYPE
PESTICIDES THE HEALTHY SOIL- HAS
A LOT OF PROGRAMS THAT ARE- IN
KEEPING WITH SUPPORTING
AGROECOLOGY AND ENCOURAGE MORE
SUPPORT OF FOR. THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND- REESTABLISHING BEAVERS AND
ALL THE SUITABLE WATERSHEDS
WOULD HELP TO REHYDRATE THE
LANDSCAPE WHICH WILL HELP GROW
GOOD FOOD THANKS. THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE
. IT DOESN'T STABILIZE WITH THE
FIRST ELEMENT FEELS LIKE- THANK
CHAIRMAN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FOR US THESE INITIATIVES ONE OF
ALSO THANK THE STATE AND
RESOURCE AGENCIES SPECIFICALLY
TEACHING M. A. R. B. FOR THE
LEADERSHIP AND THAT'S HAVE
PROGRAMS AND THEIR SELF FUNDING
TO ACCELERATE- SHELVES-
INITIATIVES HOWEVER ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR THE CALL FOR- FUNDING THINK
A LOT ABOUT HOW MILLION DOLLARS
. ONE CLASS- ZERO EMISSION OR
SEVEN FOR STRUCK AND OUT HI
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR LIGHT DUTY
AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES THE COST
TODAY ARE ABLE TO CHOOSE TO TYPE
OF SAN- BOTH IN ELECTRIC. AND
FEELS ELECTRIC AND THEY DO FOR
REASON. RESHAPED THE CHOICE THE
APPRECIATE THE OPTION TO TRY THE
SAN. THAT REPEAL JEFF THREE TO
FIVE MEN. AND THEN GOES TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILES OF RANGE. OF
PENSIONS TO SUPPORT THESE
CUSTOMERS TODAY ARE CRITICAL HI
AND ALSO FOR THE FUTURE. THE
USER- SALARY THIS HAVE AND
CARBON GOALS WITH FUNDING FOR
HER STATES. THIS WILL CERTAINTY
CERTAINTY FOR BOTH CUSTOMERS THE
TAXPAYER- OF THE CARS. AND FOR
INDUSTRY. SO THAT THEY CAN HELP
CERTAINTY THAT WILL CAUSE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT AND TO
ACCELERATE THE GROWTH OF THE
STATIONS AND SERVICE
INFRASTRUCTURE EVEN FAST. YES WE
PROVIDE SURE MISSION NO HIGH
COULD. FOR THESE CUTS. FOR
IMMEDIATE NEED AND HELP THIS.
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE WILL
THERE THE FUTURE SO WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO. MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING PROVIDES IS PROVIDED FOR
BOTH CLASSES PUBLISHER MISSION
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE NOT JUST
A SINGLE TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU.
LINE FIFTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIR. HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT
WITH MARTIN FIND LOCAL MEMBER AT
THE CENTER OF THE CONSERVATION
CORPS I AM CALLING YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR HE B. C. P.
REGARDING NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
AN UNCLE'S. LOCAL AND TRIBAL.
NATURE BIG POLLUTION COURT. WE
THE GOVERNOR APPROACH ON THE-
GREEN. IN PARTICULAR HAVE BECOME
TO THE WORK DEVELOPMENT AND
PROJECT THAT THE MEXICO LIKE
OURS WE HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THE CRITICAL A PROPOSAL
AND SUPPORT LOCAL COURT MEMBERS
LIKE ME THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TIME GET. THANK LINE SIXTY TWO.
AND SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON. I ONE SECOND
PLEASE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON. SHARE
BLOOM AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JENNY HAPPY
AT ALL I REPRESENTING COGNITIVE
DECLINE BY IN LOCATED IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY- I'M SPEAKING
REGARDING ISSUE FOR AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION AND IN UNDERSERVED
WE SUPPORT GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
BUT BASS TRACK EQUITY FUNDING OF
THE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE.
BECAUSE THESE PROGRAMS ARE
GREATLY NEEDED AS THEY ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED AS PREVIOUSLY
TODAY WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
pCARS ALL PROGRAMS B. B. TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
GOING TO THE DISTRICT WITH
EXISTING PROGRAM AND THAT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD FOR THE STATE.
PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
AND I'M CO DIRECTOR OF THE
STATEWIDE COALITION CALIFORNIANS
FOR PESTICIDE REFORM WHICH IS
MADE UP OF MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE STATE
OUR COALITION IS STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ENTIRETY OF
ITEM THREE D. PAIRS PATTERSON
ENFORCEMENT BTP AND TRAILER BILL
THE PAIR MIGHT BE UNCOMFORTABLE
STATING THAT THEY'RE COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS ARE
NOT DOING THEIR JOB. BUT THOSE
OF US WORKING ON TIME WORKING
COMMUNITIES CONFIRM CAN CONFIRM
THAT DRASTIC IMPROVEMENTS IN
STATE AND LOCAL ENFORCEMENT ARE
NEEDED JUST THE LAST TWO WEEKS
WE RECEIVED FIVE COMPLAINTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AROUND
CALIFORNIA CONCERNED ABOUT JEFF
AND ILLEGAL APPLICATIONS CLEARLY
KENNY AYE COMMISSIONERS BACKSTOP
IT'S CRITICAL THAT CALIFORNIA
LAWS AND REGULATIONS ARE
EFFECTIVELY ENFORCED IN UP THE
RESEARCH TO BE AVAILABLE TO THE
STATE TO DO SO IN A TROUBLING
HERE. ISN'T THIS ADVERTISEMENT
BETTER THAT THEIR LINCOLN ARRAY
OF THE QUEUE AND CHRONIC HUMAN
HEALTH HARMS AND WHEN THE
POLLUTANTS OF THE GREATEST
RACIAL DISPARITY IN IMPACT OF
WHAT NEXT RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA PYRMONT LIKELY TO BE
IMPACTED BY PESTICIDE EXPOSURE
AT HOME AND AT WORK PEOPLE
AREN'T ABLE TO COME IN HERE AT
THE COMPANY HEARING IN SPANISH
SOMETHING WE HOPE TO BE
ADDRESSED IN FUTURE WILL GIVE IT
WILL GIVE A MORE ACCURATE SENSE
OF THE SCOPE OF THE TOUGHEST
PROBLEM FOR CALIFORNIANS. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT FIND AN IMPORTANT
OUT OF THE FURNITURE PURPOSES
AND THAT'S BCP GO WAY TO
CORRECTING YEARS OF DECLINE AND
INSUFFICIENT. FINALLY I'M ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF JONATHAN EVANS
OF THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY ORGANIZATION I THOUGHT
THE SONG IN SUPPORT OF THE SAME
ITEM ITEM NUMBER. THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FIND SAID FIVE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN BLOWN I
GUESS IS ANGEL WITHOUT PASSED
THE REFORM AND- AUTOMATIC
ADVOCATING FOR PESTICIDE SAFETY
AND I'M SPEAKING ON ISSUE NUMBER
THREE ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT PART OF
THE PART OF PASSED THE
REGULATIONS THAT SET YOU SOME
PORTION PROGRAM AND BUDGET
TRAILER BILL SPECIFICALLY WE
SUPPORT ALLOCATION FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR DPR TO
INVESTIGATE AND- THE BALLOT THE
PORCELAIN PIECES REACTIVITY PR'S
- AUTHORITY TO PAT THANK USED
BY. AND TO TOPPING PENALTIES
THAT USUALLY A QUICK
EXTRAPOLATION OF DPR PASSED THAT
USE DATA ILLUSTRATE A PROTECTIVE
HEAVILY USING CONCENTRATED IN
COUNTIES WITH LARGE FLAT NEXT
POPULATIONS THIS TREND NEEDS TO
STOP. AND THIS IS ONE. SMALL
STEPS TOWARDS ADDRESSING. THAT
LONG HISTORY OF AT ENVIRONMENT-
IN JUST. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE NO FURTHER LINES INTO ALL
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP OPERATORS AND DEALT WITH
THAT OUR MEETING COMES TO A
CONCLUSION WE STAND ADJOURNED.